Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. if you came this way taking any route starting from anywhere at any time or at any season it would always be the same you would have to put off sense and notion you are not here to verify instruct yourself or inform curiosity or carry report you are here to kneel where prayer has been valid that was T.S. Eliot in Little Gidding the last of the four quartets and Little Gidding is a very beautiful tiny little church very hard to find that was the final point in my recent exciting tour of middle england which um dominic has laughed at me about but it it was laughing now it was uh it was a kind of a wonderful wonderful
感谢收听《历史的余烬》。想要收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告音频、系列节目的抢先体验，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。无论你以什么方式、从哪里出发、在什么时候或什么季节来到这条路上，结果总是相同的，你都得抛开世俗的感官与概念；你来这里不是为了求证、自我教导、满足好奇心，也不是为了带走什么见闻；你来这里是为了在祈祷依然神圣的地方下跪。那是T·S·艾略特在《小吉丁》（四首四重奏的最后一部）中的诗句。小吉丁是一座非常美丽、极难找到的小教堂，这也是我最近令人兴奋的中英格兰之旅的最后一站——多米尼克虽然对此嘲笑过我，但这其实是一次非常奇妙的、美妙的
place and a reminder that um in a sense uh churches are among our most kind of intimate way to to get in touch with history um ell um again in in little giving elliot famously said that history is a pattern of timeless moments and you kind of can really feel that i think in churches or am i being overly romantic dominic no i don't think you are at all i think uh certainly um to bring out my inner john bull which is never much suppressed i think england's wealth of of parish churches is the envy of any country in the world i mean these fantastic historical sites whereas you say the sort of the the layers of the of the past just seem to kind of strip away as you walk inside the church and you
经历，它提醒我们，从某种意义上说，教堂是我们接触历史最亲密的方式之一。艾略特在《小吉丁》中曾有句名言，历史是超越时间的时刻构成的图案，我想在教堂里你真的能感受到这一点，还是说我太浪漫主义了，多米尼克？不，我觉得一点也没有。我认为，当然了，为了展现我骨子里那种永不褪色的约翰·布尔式爱国情怀，英格兰丰富的乡村教堂绝对是世上任何国家都羡慕的宝藏。我是说，这些绝佳的历史遗址，就像你说的，当你走进教堂时，历史的层层面貌似乎就一层层剥落，而你
you know you're standing where generations of people stood you're looking at what you know endless generations have looked at and a place that they took immensely seriously they're kind of even now you don't have to be a believer to feel that these places are kind of weighed down with the solemnity and the seriousness of of the sort of faith of ages yeah and also i mean the coming of christianity and then the reformation and then i suppose the sort of faith of ages. Yeah, and also, I mean, the coming of Christianity and then the Reformation, and then I suppose the process of de-Christianization has such profound influences on English, British, Irish history that I think that an episode devoted
知道自己正站在世世代代人们曾经站过的地方，你看着无数代人曾经凝视的事物，这是一个他们极其严肃对待的地方。甚至在现在，你不需要是一个信徒，也能感受到这些地方沉甸甸地压着历史岁月的虔诚与庄严。是的，而且基督教的传入、宗教改革，以及后来的去基督教化进程，对英国、不列颠、爱尔兰的历史产生了如此深远的影响，以至于我认为，做一期专门探讨
to what churches can tell us about the past is more than justified. And I just want to put it on record because there has been suggestion on Twitter that the fact that you've had covid this past week and have i have it as we speak i have it as we speak i've risen from my sickbed to do this wow i mean this is this is like a kind of yeah something from the bible in itself it is um but people have suggested that i have snuck this in while you've been. But actually, Dominic, this is your idea, isn't it? Yes, it pains me to admit it, but it is my idea.
教堂能告诉我们哪些关于过去的故事的节目是绝对有必要的。我必须澄清一点，因为推特上有人猜测，上周你得了新冠，而且正如我们所说，我现在正带着新冠录音——我确实带着新冠呢，我是从病榻上爬起来录节目的。哇，这简直就像是《圣经》里的情节一样。确实是。但人们猜测我是趁你……不过，多米尼克，这其实是你的主意，对吧？是的，虽然我很不情愿承认，但确实是我的主意。
Because, Tom, I happen to know the absolute best person in the entire British Isles to... You can't say British Isles. I just did. The Atlantic Archipelago, I believe. Inside British Isles to talk about did. The Atlantic Archipelago I believe. Inside British Isles to talk about churches. She's an Irish woman. Her name is Rachel Morley. She's a former winner of Person of the Year at her old school. She's the director of the Friends of Friendless Churches and most of all her big claim to fame she is my sister-in-law and here she is hello rachel hello ronnie rachel hi tom
因为，汤姆，我恰好知道不列颠群岛上最适合……你不能说不列颠群岛。我刚说了。大西洋群岛，我想应该这么说。不列颠群岛内部关于……大西洋群岛，我想是的。不列颠群岛内部关于教堂的探讨。她是一位爱尔兰女性，名叫雷切尔·莫利。她是她母校当年的年度人物获得者，她是“无主教堂之友”组织的负责人，而她最大的名气是——她是我小姨子。她来了，哈喽，雷切尔。哈喽，罗尼。雷切尔，嗨，汤姆。
thanks for that dominic you're very welcome you were person of the year i was embarrassed about it no i'm not embarrassed i was person of the year but i find it very strange that you suggested this topic because anytime when i come to visit and i talk about churches or i bring them up you always just kind of put your head in your hands and say not a bloody not another bloody church there's a lot of rolling of eyes goes on in my house yeah exactly so um so I'm surprised uh I'm as surprised as anybody to be here today so Rachel Rachel actually wants to live with us Tom she lived with us for uh 18 months no only about 10 oh it felt like it felt like. Did you take Dominic around lots of churches? I hope so.
谢谢你的介绍，多米尼克。不客气。你曾是年度人物？我当时觉得挺尴尬的。不，我不尴尬，我是年度人物，但我发现你居然会提议这个主题真的很奇怪，因为每次我来拜访时，只要我聊起教堂或者提起它们，你总是双手抱头说：“天哪，别又是该死的教堂了。”我家里总是伴随着各种翻白眼。对，没错。所以我对今天能来到这里感到很惊讶，和任何人一样惊讶。雷切尔其实想跟我们住在一起，汤姆。她跟我们住了大约18个月……不，只有10个月左右。哦，感觉像18个月。你带多米尼克去过很多教堂吗？希望如此。
I did not, no. Oh, missed opportunity. He wouldn't come with me. There's no point. What can you do with this man? I know, I know. No, but this is ridiculous because Dominic has suggested this subject.
我没有，真的。哦，错失良机。他不肯跟我去。根本没用。你拿这个人怎么办？我知道，我知道。不，这太荒谬了，因为这个主题是多米尼克提议的。
So Dominic, I mean, this is a great theme. This is a great theme. So how are we going to do this? Rachel, you have chosen your, I mean, we said 10 best. Best is, I mean so let's how are we going to do this we get rachel you have um chosen your i mean we said 10 best best is i mean it's a hopeless phrase 10 top churches and we put so i put i put a request for for kind of people's suggestions on on twitter and i don't think we've ever had um quite the response that we had that i mean we had more people reply to that than i think anything we put out before an immense range of uh of suggestions um dominic we had what did we have we had um we had uh some entirely predictable ones from yeah people who've appeared on the show so
所以，多米尼克，这是一个绝佳的主题。这是一个绝佳的主题。那我们该怎么做呢？雷切尔，你已经选出了——我是说，我们说过十佳。最佳，我是说……那我们到底该怎么做？雷切尔，你已经选出了——我是说，我们说过十佳。最佳，我是说这个词太无望了，十座顶级教堂。我们发起了——我在推特上征求了大家的建议，我觉得我们从未获得过像这次这么热烈的反响。我的意思是，回复这条推特的人比我们以往发布过的任何内容都要多，我们收到了极其广泛的各种建议。多米尼克，我们都有什么？我们有……
dan jackson uh author of uh northumbrians um obviously went for a northern church they were all northumbrian ones um jonathan wilson um son of sunderland he went for st peter church monk weirmouth which is of course a brilliant choice um that's the one um that uh famous for beadede the glory of the North East, what else did we have we had, so Rachel we had a lot of enthusiasm for Durham Cathedral
丹·杰克逊，著有《诺森布里亚人》，他显然选了一座北方的教堂，它们全都是诺森布里亚的教堂；乔纳森·威尔逊，桑德兰之子，他选了蒙克威茅斯的圣彼得教堂，这当然是个绝妙的选择。那就是因贝德而闻名的一座……东北部的荣耀。我们还有什么？雷切尔，我们对达勒姆座堂有极大的热情。
we had Simon Sharma yeah he chose Magnus Cathedral Kirkwall do you agree with that choice Rach? I do not, no well okay the reason why is because you asked for churches and so many people gave you cathedrals I mean that's right a rookie's error well it's not what you asked for so why would they be telling you cathedrals? Simon Sharma didn't even read the question. He didn't even read the question exactly so there we go um and I guess the thing is uh I'm
我们还有西蒙·沙玛，是的，他选择了柯克沃尔的马格尼特座堂。你同意这个选择吗，雷切尔？不，我不同意。好吧，原因很简单，因为你要求的是教堂，而那么多人给你的却是座堂。我是说，这是一个新手才会犯的错误。但这并不是你要求的，所以他们为什么会告诉你座堂呢？西蒙·沙玛甚至都没读题。他甚至都没读题，完全如此。所以就是这样。而且我觉得……
really nervous because this is a massive responsibility okay um and it's been done so many times before like obviously betjeman did his best british churches right yes and on that yes so on that just sorry just so we also have him for giles fraser um famous vicar famous vicar famous vicar top vicar um and he suggested st ennardock yeah yeah st ennardock uh in north cornwall which is a wonderful church um has a spire that looks like the tail of a stegosaur um and it's but also it's where john betjeman is buried and john betjeman he loved his churches didn't rachel has been to st ennardock church with me i have oh so you have been to a church dominic i have, yes. It's a great church.
我真的很紧张，因为这是一项巨大的责任，好吧，而且这件事以前已经被做过太多次了。比如，贝杰曼显然写过他的《英国最佳教堂》，对吧？是的。说到这个，抱歉，我们还有贾尔斯·弗雷泽——著名的牧师，著名的牧师，顶级牧师。他推荐了北康沃尔的圣埃纳多克教堂，那是一座非常棒的教堂，它的尖顶看起来像剑龙的尾巴。这也是约翰·贝杰曼长眠的地方。约翰·贝杰曼热爱他的教堂，不是吗？雷切尔曾和我一起去过圣埃纳多克教堂。我去过。所以你确实去过教堂，多米尼克。是的，去过。那是一座很棒的教堂。
It used to be covered by sand dunes, didn't it, Rach? It did, yeah, exactly. And it's got a golf course all round it. It does, yeah, it does, it does. The vicar used to have to climb down through a ladder, didn't he, in the roof? In the spire, yeah. In the spire.
它以前曾被沙丘覆盖，对吧，雷切尔？是的，确实如此。而且它四周都是高尔夫球场。没错，确实是。牧师以前不得不通过屋顶上的梯子爬下去，对吧？在尖顶里，是的。在尖顶里。
Because it was just poking out through the sand, yeah. So, Rach, does that qualify St. Anadoc as one of the top churches? It's great church it's not on my list oh okay okay so we said what are the qualifications you brought for your choice of the top 10 and we're including ireland as well as britain well we'll see about that um let's just say okay so betjeman has done it he did a thousand best churches there's's Alec Clifton-Taylor, there's Pevsner. They're kind of like the giants of 20th century talking about churches.
因为它只是从沙堆里探出头来，是的。那么，雷切尔，这使得圣埃纳多克教堂有资格入选顶级教堂吗？这是一座很棒的教堂，但它不在我的名单上。哦，好吧，好吧。我们之前说过，你挑选前十名的标准是什么？我们把爱尔兰也算进去了，还有不列颠。好吧，那我们拭目以待。我们就说……贝杰曼做过了，他写了《一千座最佳教堂》。还有亚历克·克利夫顿-泰勒，还有佩夫斯纳。他们可以说是20世纪探讨教堂的泰斗。
And Simon Jenkins. Oh, yeah, and Simon Jenkins. But he sort of just ripped off Betjeman doing his thousand best churches. Well, he did. Hard-hitting opinion on churches here. We've got him. And also, he didn't even go to all of the churches and some that are on my list are in his a thousand best churches
还有西蒙·詹金斯。哦，对，还有西蒙·詹金斯。但他基本上就是抄袭了贝杰曼的《一千座最佳教堂》。好吧，他确实抄了。这里有对教堂直言不讳的犀利评价。我们抓住他了。而且，他甚至没有去过所有的教堂，我名单上有些教堂就在他那本《一千座最佳教堂》里。
which i think is just you know terrible that he uh yeah but also i think there's a there's a book that's the nation's favorite churches but again loads of people voted for cathedrals on that which i just don't understand i mean there are like 16 000 churches in england alone you have loads of choice you don't have to go for the obvious cathedrals anyway and then there's Jay Hume on Twitter and last year he did a um he did a world cup of major churches which was hugely popular um and the final two I think were uh Saint Saint Wolfram's in Grantham in Lincolnshire and Tewkesbury Abbey and in the end St. Wolfram's in Grantham home of Isaac Newton and well not home but he went to school there and Margaret Thatcher and that one won so that was very that was very interesting but basically uh thinking about it I was thinking
我觉得这简直太糟糕了，他居然……是的。不过，我还觉得有一本书叫《国民最爱的教堂》，但同样地，很多人在上面投票投给了座堂，这让我完全无法理解。我是说，仅在英格兰就有大约16,000座教堂，你有大量的选择，没必要非得选那些显眼的大座堂。不管怎样，推特上还有个杰·休姆，去年他举办了一场主要教堂的世界杯，非常受欢迎。最后进入决赛的两座教堂，我想是林肯郡格兰瑟姆的圣沃尔弗姆教堂和蒂克斯伯里修道院。最终，艾萨克·牛顿的故乡——或者说不是故乡，但他在那里上过学——以及玛格丽特·撒尔顿所在的格兰瑟姆的圣沃尔弗姆教堂赢了。这非常有趣。不过基本上，我在思考时就在想：
okay so what do you go for for the best you go go for the oldest, the biggest, the finest interior, the one with the tallest spire, the longest nave, the smallest? I mean, if you're doing cathedrals, you want to go for the tallest spire. Okay. I mean, I think we can all agree that Salisbury is the best cathedral. It's not as good as Lincoln. It's not as good as Lincoln. Lincoln's a better cathedral.
好吧，评选“最佳”时，你会选择什么样的标准？是最古老的、最大的、内部装饰最精美的、尖顶最高的、中殿最长的、还是最小的？如果你在评选座堂，你大概会选尖顶最高的。好吧。我想我们都可以一致认为索尔兹伯里是最好的座堂。它不如林肯。它不如林肯。林肯是一座更好的座堂。
No, because Lincoln's fell down. Go on, Rachel. Because it was so great. Don't listen to Tom Holland. Anyway, that's fine. Talk over him. Okay, okay great I will and then there are the things like you know you've got churches that are called like you know the cathedral of the marshes the queen of the moors all of these and those are all kind of like great
不，因为林肯教堂倒塌过。说吧，雷切尔。因为它太伟大了。别听汤姆·霍兰的。不管怎样，没关系。打断他。好吧，好吧，太棒了，我会的。然后还有一些教堂，比如被称为“沼泽座堂”、“荒野女王”之类的，这些全都是非常
churches but the thing is whenever you do lists and compile things like this it's always the same ones that come out you always get the same ones there's Saint Peter's Walpole Saint Peter's in Norfolk there's Saint Mary's Redcliffe in Bristol roslyn chapel fairford longmelford burford you know so there's no point in me going through all of those because everybody knows those and you know there are so many churches to choose from there are 42 000 places of worship around 42 000 places of worship in the uk so you know let's kind of let's look for actually ones that are a bit more interesting and not obvious choices so that's brilliant mine okay is that okay yeah that that is a that's fantastic specification nothing obvious basically okay so it's so your top 10 unobvious
伟大的教堂。但问题是，无论你什么时候做列表、整理这样的东西，总是那些老面孔脱颖而出。你总是能看到同样的那些：诺福克的沃尔普圣彼得教堂、布里斯托尔的圣玛丽雷德克利夫教堂、罗斯林教堂、费尔福德、朗米尔福德、伯福德等等。所以，我再去一一列举这些毫无意义，因为每个人都知道它们。你知道，有那么多的教堂可供选择，英国大约有42,000处礼拜场所。所以，让我们去寻找那些实际上更有趣、不是显而易见的选择。这太棒了，我的……这样可以吗？对，那是一个非常棒的规格——基本上就是不要那些显而易见的选择，对吧？
yeah churches yeah i i have you are they in random order are you going from 10 to 1 or well they're sort of in random order what i tried to do was try and make a nice story so that they all they all kind of flow into one and the other we like a story oh we do like a story so yeah okay so what's so what are you kicking off with okay i'm kicking off with one which is one that I really like, obviously, because it's in my top 10. But I used to live near St. Mary the Virgin in Shrewsbury. And I absolutely love Shrewsbury. Dominic knows it's my favourite place in the whole of England. And St. Mary's Shrewsbury is a great church. You know, the river sort of carves out Shrewsbury,
好的，那么你的前十名“非显眼”教堂……
the river defines Shrewsbury and the town sort of rises up from there and St Mary's is kind of at the top of that and it's a gorgeous old red sandstone church. It's got a great big spire. That's all lovely. The reason why I'm bringing it in, first of all, is that it's got a really, not just about the architecture,
对的。你是按随机顺序排列的，还是从10到1倒序？它们算是随机排列的。我试图做的是串起一个美好的故事，让它们彼此自然衔接、流畅过渡。我们喜欢故事。哦，我们确实喜欢故事。所以，好的，那你以哪个开场？好的，我以一个我非常喜欢的教堂开场，显然如此，因为它在我的前十名里。我以前住在什鲁斯伯里的圣玛丽童贞教堂附近。我绝对爱极了什鲁斯伯里。多米尼克知道那是整个英格兰我最喜欢的地方。什鲁斯伯里的圣玛丽教堂是一座伟大的教堂。你知道，河流环绕着什鲁斯伯里，
but it's got a really interesting story around it. Dominic, I don't know if you know this you're a Shropshire native aren't you uh I don't know this I am a Shropshire native I blank out all church stuff because I leave that to you okay thanks so anyway it's all about uh the story is all about Robert Cadman and he was an 18th century steeplejack and rope slider and he used to perform all of these sorts of tricks and he was from Shrewsbury which rope slider and he used to perform all of these sorts of tricks and he was from shrewsbury which is lovely and he traveled kind of all around the country so he's in dorset and lincoln newspaper kind of saying these great feats of daring that this guy used to do um and he one of his kind of big tricks was he would climb up the front of saint mary's which
河流定义了什鲁斯伯里，镇子顺着地势从河边升起，圣玛丽教堂就坐落在最高处。那是一座华丽的古老红砂岩教堂。它有一个巨大无比的尖顶。这一切都美极了。我把它列入其中的原因，首先不仅仅是因为它的建筑风格，
is you know a bits of a norman church in there so it's a really ancient church so he'd climb up the front of St. Mary's, which is, you know, bits of a Norman church in there, so it's a really ancient church, so he'd climb up the front of it. It was 250 metres up the church, then a 68-metre spire up to the top. He'd have a rope going from the top of the spire down and anchored into a meadow across the other side of the river.
而是它背后有一个非常有趣的故事。多米尼克，我不知道你知不知道——你是什罗普郡本地人，对吧？我不知道。我是什罗普郡本地人，但我把所有关于教堂的事情都屏蔽了，因为我把这些留给你。好的，谢谢。不管怎样，这个故事的主角是罗伯特·卡德曼（Robert Cadman），他是一位18世纪的高空修缮工和高空滑索表演者。他过去常常表演各种各样的绝技。他是什罗普郡人，
So as he's going up, he's doing all kinds of sorts of, you know, tricks and making the crowd laugh and everyone's having a great jolly time. time anyway he gets to the top and then he puts on a wooden breastplate and there's a big groove down the center of it and he hurls himself onto this rope and he's meant to slide all the way from the top of the spire over the river over the meadows and kind of land you know perfectly standing on the other side. In one piece, preferably. He did that several times. That was fine. Except once.
这很可爱。他到处旅行——去过多塞特、林肯郡——当地报纸都会报道这个家伙完成的那些惊人壮举。他的一项“大绝招”就是爬上圣玛丽教堂的前面——
Which was kind of the end of it. The last time he did it. Which was 1739. When the rope actually snapped. And he fell. And he died. So that's very sad. Oh.
那是一座部分带有诺曼风格的古老教堂，所以是一座非常古老的教堂——他会沿着教堂正面爬上去。那是距离地面250米高的教堂，然后还要攀登68米高的尖顶到达顶部。他会拉起一根绳子，从尖顶顶端一直延伸并固定在河对岸的一片草地上。
But there's a plaque on the outside of the church. So right by the main door as you go in. So it's a big event in the church's history, right? So there's a plaque outside and it reads, Let this small monument record the name of Cadman and to the future time proclaim how by an attempt to fly from this spire across the Sabrina stream,
当他往上爬的时候，他会做各种各样的杂技动作，逗得观众哈哈大笑，每个人都玩得很开心。不管怎样，他爬到了顶端，然后穿上一件木制胸甲，胸甲正中央有一道大凹槽。接着，他把自己投掷到这条滑索上，打算一路从尖顶滑过河流、滑过草地，然后完美地……比如说，双脚稳稳地站在对岸。至少要留个全尸。他这么做过好几次，都没问题。除了最后一次。
he did acquire his fatal end. It was not for want of skill or courage to perform the task he fell. But no, no, a faulty cord being drawn too tight hurried his soul on her high to take her flight, which bit the body here beneath good night. So that's lovely. So he's basically a failed tightrope walker. No, I mean, he had loads of success. He died when he was 28, but he had loads of success and he died when he's 28 but he had lots of success live fast die young but but yeah but but it's a really cool story anyway but beyond that the
这也是故事的终结。那是他最后一次表演，在1739年。当时滑索真的断了。他坠落了。然后他死了。所以这非常悲惨。哦。
church is really interesting so the actual building is great too go on tom i was just going to say on the topic of of kind of jumping off the top of churches um you've given dominic a shrewsbury one a shropshire one could i could i there's a famous wiltshire uh oh go on yeah um which is um uh ailmer of malmsbury the monk who um built himself a glider and hurled himself off the top of malmsbury and um he crash landed and lost the use of his legs but he didn't die. Oh, okay. So I'm just sticking up for... The people who jump off churches in Wiltshire are slightly better at it
但在教堂外墙上有一块牌匾。就在你进去的正门旁边。所以这是教堂历史上的一件大事，对吧？所以在外面有一块牌匾，上面写着：“让这座小纪念碑记录下卡德曼的名字，向未来的人们宣告：他试图从这座尖顶飞过萨布丽娜河时，迎来了他致命的结局。这并非由于缺乏完成任务的技巧或勇气而坠落。然而，一根有缺陷的绳索拉得太紧，匆忙催促着他的灵魂高高飞去，把这具肉体留在此地，晚安。”这很可爱。所以他基本上是一个失败走钢丝的人。不，我的意思是，他取得了巨大的成功。他死时28岁，但他曾取得过无数成功——虽然死时28岁，但他有过很多辉煌。及时行乐，英年早逝。不过，这确实是个很酷的故事。除此之外，
than people who jump off it in Shropshire. I'd rather be killed. You might prefer to be killed outright, I think. It depends how... No, because then you have a long, profitable life as a hero of aeronautics. Well, a failed hero of aeronautics, surely. No, the glider worked anyway listen we're getting off and i'm just anyway i'm top 10 gliders rather than churches
这座教堂也非常有趣，建筑本身也很棒。汤姆，请讲。我只是想说，关于从教堂顶部跳下来这件事……你给多米尼克讲了一个什鲁斯伯里的、什罗普郡的故事，我能不能讲一个？威尔茨郡有个著名的……哦，讲吧。那就是马姆斯伯里的埃尔默，那个僧侣，他自己做了一个滑翔机，把自己从马姆斯伯里修道院顶部扔了下去，结果硬着陆摔断了腿，但他没死。哦，好吧。所以我只是想为……相比于什罗普郡那些跳教堂的人，威尔茨郡跳教堂的人稍微擅长一点。我宁愿直接被摔死。你可能宁愿直接被摔死，我想。这取决于……不，因为那样你就能作为航空英雄度过漫长而功成名就的一生了。好吧，是个失败的航空英雄，当然啦。不，滑翔机其实成功了……不管怎样，我们扯远了。我只关心高空滑索，而不是教堂。
dominic um i thought i guess i kind of thought of you with this one obviously there's a shrub shrub to your connection but also you recently did a nice go ape challenge so you were doing your own bit of rope sliding i did would you would you mean, do you think you were as good as Cadman? I was terrified. Tell us about this. I didn't know anything about this. We went in the summer. We went and did Go Ape with my son and two of his friends.
多米尼克，我猜这个话题能让你感同身受。显然这与什罗普郡有渊源，而且你最近还挑战了“森林高空酷跑”（Go Ape），你也在进行属于自己的高空滑索。我做过。你觉得你和卡德曼一样厉害吗？我当时吓坏了。跟我们讲讲这个。我对此一无所知。我们在夏天去的。我们和我的两个儿子以及他的两个朋友一起去玩了Go Ape。
Now, the two friends had difficulties completing the course, so that left me and Arthur. And I found it absolutely terrifying. So Go Ape, for people who don't know, is this thing where you've got kind of platforms and walkways and kind of adventure playgrounds, I think, suspended high in trees. It's for sort of daredevil-type activity.
结果，那两个朋友很难完成整个路线，所以最后只剩下我和亚瑟。我发现这简直太可怕了。所以，Go Ape对那些不知道的人来说，就是一种由高高悬挂在树林中的平台、走道和冒险游乐场组成的设施。它是为那些喜欢寻求刺激的人准备的活动。
And I kind of thought... Does Dominic strike you as a daredevil? An intellectual daredevil, surely. I'm loving this insight into how actually found it is seen by i thought i was going to have a heart attack i was so so terrified there was a thing we had to do climbing wall suspended between two trees um uh and it was a way of getting from tree to tree so jumping off churches wouldn't be your bag um i don't think it would i did there's a lot of zip wires involved in go ape so i mean that's basically what was going on in Shrewsbury
我当时还想……多米尼克给你的印象是个寻求刺激的人吗？一个思想上的寻求刺激者，当然啦。我很喜欢这种深入了解大家如何看待……我当时以为自己要心脏病发作了，实在是太害怕了。其中有一个项目是我们需要爬一堵悬挂在两棵树之间的攀爬墙……这也是从一棵树移动到另一棵树的方式。所以从教堂上跳下去可不是你的菜。我觉得不是。Go Ape里包含了很多滑索，所以这基本上就是什鲁斯伯里发生的那一幕，对吧？
isn't it? exactly so yeah great choice Rachel oh that's fine but anyway just to say a couple more things about that church because it is gorgeous so it's lots of lovely Norman bits
完全正确。所以，这是一个绝佳的选择，雷切尔。哦，那太好了。不过，关于那座教堂，我只想再补充几点，因为它是真的美。那里有很多可爱的诺曼风格建筑，
lovely old red sandstone but when you go in it's got an amazing 15th century roof carved timber roof in the nave but i think probably the real kind of crowning glory of the church is the stained glass so it's got an almost complete jesse window in the east window from about 1330 it did come from the old saint chad's in shrewsbury which was um which collapsed uh unfortunately um but they've got that stained glass but also in all of the other windows or most of the other windows it's got some of the best collection of um 16th and 15th and 16th century continental stained glass I mean it's amazing you could spend hours looking at stained glass there it's just gorgeous but also if you're
美丽的古老红砂岩。当你走进去时，你会看到中殿里有一个惊人的15世纪木雕屋顶。但我认为，这座教堂真正的皇冠上的明珠可能是彩色玻璃。它在东窗处几乎保留了一扇完整的杰西窗，大约制作于1330年。它原本来自什鲁斯伯里的老圣查德教堂，由于不幸坍塌……但他们保留了这扇彩色玻璃。不仅如此，在所有其他窗户中——或者大部分其他窗户中——它拥有15世纪和16世纪大陆彩色玻璃的最佳收藏之一。我是说，这太惊人了，你可以在那里花上几个小时欣赏彩色玻璃，简直美极了。而且，如果你在什鲁斯伯里，你还可以去圣阿尔克曼教堂、圣查德教堂、修道院，你还可以去老集市大厅……你是收了什鲁斯伯里旅游局的钱吗？我倒是挺想的。我很想为什罗普郡旅游局工作。雷切尔，我能快速问你一个问题吗？当你去教堂时，经常会听到导游说：“哦，那扇彩色玻璃窗在宗教改革中被毁了。”被摧毁了，或者被克伦威尔的骑兵开枪打碎了之类的。这有多大程度是真的？你知道吗？我是说，这是一个……我猜其中有些是真的吧？但总的来说，认为所有彩色玻璃窗都在宗教改革中被砸碎的这种想法……我觉得，嗯，主要有两点。这取决于它们描绘了什么内容，以及它有多显眼，我想。但是，是的，我想其中一部分确实被毁了。我不知道。
in Shrewsbury you can also go to St. Elkman's's, St Chad's, the Abbey, you can go to the Old Market Hall and are you being paid by the Shrewsbury tourist board? I would like to be yeah I would like to work for Shropshire Tourism and Rachel can I just ask you just very quickly it's often when you go to churches you'll be told oh the stained glass window got destroyed in the reformation destroyed but shot by cromwell's troopers or whatever yeah how true is that do you know i mean is it is it a uh i imagine some of them were yeah but by and large by and large the idea that all stained glass window got smashed in the reformation um i mean i guess well, I guess two things. It depended on what it depicted and how obvious it was, I suppose, you know. But yeah, I guess some of it was. I don't know.
我不认为全部都被毁了。当然没有全部被毁。有一些很棒的幸存下来。大概那些更具具象风格的、或者明显带有教皇色彩的东西，
I don't think all of it was. I mean, definitely all of it wasn't. There's some great survivals. Presumably the more figurative, but also the more obviously sort of papist it was. Yeah. The more likely it was to be destroyed. It must be as simple as that, surely. And just whether the
就更有可能被摧毁。事情肯定就这么简单吧？而且，只要看这座教堂是否曾在某个时刻被士兵占领过，
church was occupied by at some point by soldiers yeah like like burford let's say yeah soldiers were billeted were in the church yeah yeah anyway rachel we're going far too slowly i know okay i'm going and this is a big one that was meant to be my short one so we need to hurry up um okay so uh from there uh my my kind of seamless uh segue into the next one is so that was you know great feats of daring you know brilliant people so there I go to North Wales to St Beno
比如伯福德，对吧？士兵曾被驻扎在教堂里。不管怎样，雷切尔，我们进度太慢了。我知道，好的。我要加快了。这是一个比较大的话题，原本打算当成简短的介绍来说，所以我们需要抓紧。好的。那么，从那里开始——我无缝衔接下一个话题：那是一些伟大的壮举、了不起的人物——接下来我要去北威尔士的格温内德，去看看克利农法尔的圣拜诺教堂。你知道这个吗，汤姆？不知道。好的，太好了。多米尼克，我知道你也不知道，所以问你也没用。抱歉，我知道你不知道。我知道你不知道。不管怎样……不知道我在问你什么。抱歉，我知道你不知道。不管怎样，圣拜诺可能是威尔士最重要的圣徒之一，
Clinog Fair in Gwynedd. Do you know this one Tom? No. Okay great. Dominic I know you don't know so there's no point asking you. Sorry I know you don't. I know you don't. Anyway doesn't know what i'm asking you um sorry i know you don't i know you don't anyway so um st beno was probably one of the most important saints in wales um definitely in north wales uh his name me it's kind of a mutation of old watch and it means knowing cattle so even
绝对是北威尔士最重要的圣徒。他的名字是古威尔士语的变体，意思是“精通养牛的”。所以这并不是一个你想用的名字。不过直到今天，他仍然是患病牲畜和儿童的主保圣人。所以就是这样。因此，从这个名字你可能会认为拜诺来自农业背景，但他其实并不是。他是7世纪一位诗人之王的孙子，最终他选择了修道院而非王权。他前往班戈并成为了一名修道院院长。他是一位传教士，四处旅行，这都很棒。
that's not a name you want but also to day, he's still the patron saint of sick cattle and children. So there we go. So anyway, from that, you might think that Baino came from an agricultural background, but he didn't, actually. He was a grandson of a king of poets in the 7th century, and ultimately he chose the monastery over the monarchy. He packed off to Bangor and he became an abbot. He was a missionary, he travelled around a lot, that's all great.
总共有11座教堂供奉着他。其中一座是最小的教堂之一，位于萨默塞特郡科尔本的圣拜诺教堂，非常漂亮。但我想谈的是克利农法尔的圣拜诺教堂，它位于利群岛上。这是一座15世纪的庞然大物。它美极了，巨大无比，空间极其宽广。它有华丽的……采用的是素玻璃窗，东窗没有彩色玻璃，但它有屏风、
There's 11 churches in total dedicated to him. One is the smallest, one of the smallest, St Benoist, Colborne and Somerset, which is very nice. But the one I want to talk about is St Benoist, Clunag Farr, and that's on the Clim Peninsula. And it is a 15th century whopper like it's just it's gorgeous it's huge it's massive big massive space it's got this gorgeous it's plain glazing no stained glass in the east window and but it's got you know a screen
唱诗班座席护手板，还有一个漂亮的卷叶饰……抱歉，多米尼克，你不会喜欢我用这些专业术语的。我知道，我之前被警告过不要用人们听不懂的术语。不管怎样，还有卷叶饰的座席等等，这些都很棒。这座教堂曾经是拜诺修道院的所在地，所以它非常有趣。拜诺就安葬在这里，他被安葬在修道院的小堂里。但修道院和小堂在10世纪时都被维京人摧毁了。
misery cord it's got a lovely crocketed and sorry Dominic you won't like me using technical terms I know I was warned off using terms that people would people wouldn't know but anyway crocketed sedilia all of that sort of stuff it's great and but this church was the site of this the monastery St Beno's monastery so it's really interesting Beno was buried here he was interred in the monastery chapel. But the monastery and the chapel were both destroyed by Vikings in the 10th century. Coming from Ireland, presumably.
他们是从爱尔兰来的吗？是吗？维京人为什么会攻击北威尔士？他们是从都柏林还是什么地方来的？可能吧。你不在乎吗？我其实不在乎，因为这不在我的故事里，而且我也没有时间谈论这些。不管怎样，还有很多要说的。有趣的是，马路对面有一口圣拜诺圣泉。据说如果你去朝圣，可以去这口圣泉，
Were they? Why would Vikings be attacking North Wales? Were they coming from Dublin or something? Maybe, yeah. You don't care? I don't really care because that's not on my story and I have no time to talk about all this anyway so there's loads to say so anyway what's interesting is across the road there's a holy well and with saint beno's holy well and apparently if you went on your pilgrimage you could go to this holy well uh you could be dunked into the water and you
把自己浸入水中，就能治愈从癫痫、佝偻病到阳痿等各种疾病。但为了让它起效，你必须先在井里狠狠地泡个澡，然后过马路去教堂，在拜诺的墓顶上睡上一晚。这太棒了。这种习俗一直延续到了18世纪。但现在没人这么做了。现在没人这么做了，因为维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，维京人没来，取而代之的是维京人……不，维多利亚人来了，他们说陵墓不安全，于是把它拆了。
would be cured of anything from epilepsy, rickets and impotence. But to make it work, you had to go for a big dunking in the well, then go across the road to the church and sleep on top of Baino's grave for the night. So that was great. And then that was all fine. And that was actually a practice that continued until the 1700s. But nobody does it now. Nobody does it now because rather than the Vikings, the Victorians came along and said that the tomb was unsafe,
哦，为了健康和安全。为了健康和安全，是的。维多利亚时代的健康与安全。真是活见鬼。卡德曼的杰出天赋是顺着绳子滑下来，而拜诺的杰出天赋是让人死而复生。他做过很多次这样的事。这太棒了，其中包括他的侄女温妮弗雷德。她选择当一名修女，但她被抛弃的情人砍掉了她的脑袋——在7、8世纪、6、7世纪的威尔士，当圣徒似乎是一种职业危险。不过，弗林特郡的圣温妮弗雷德圣泉就是她头颅落地的地方，据说泉水从那里涌出，它实际上是威尔士最受欢迎的地方之一，绝对美极了，被称为“威尔士的洛雷托”。所以这很棒。
so they dismantled it. Oh, health and safety. For health and safety, yeah. Victorian health and safety. Goodness sake. But so Cadman's great gift, sort of, was sliding down ropes. Baino's great gift is bringing people back from the dead. So he did this lots of times. That was great, and it included his niece Winifred. She chose to be a nun, her
那现在还有人去那里寻求治愈吗？对，太棒了。有多少人？很多人吗？好多人。不管怎样，简单快速地说一下——因为关于拜诺有太多精彩的故事了——其实我最喜欢的一个是：基本上，他当时非常受欢迎，每个人都想从他身上沾点光、想去他的修道院等等，所以他需要一点时间来祈祷。
jilted lover chopped off her head, which seems to be an occupational hazard if you were a saint in Wales kind of back in the 7th, 8th century, 6th, 7th century. But Saint Winifred's well in Flintshire is on the site where her head fell off and apparently the spring came up and it's actually it's one of the most popular places in Wales absolutely gorgeous, it's called the Lords of Wales so that's great
于是他过去常常做的事是：走到河中央，那里有一块岩石，他晚上就跪在河里的岩石上祈祷。有一天晚上，他被吵到了，于是他低声嘟囔了一句。显然他有直通上帝的专线，所以他说了一些类似于“应该给那个人一点教训”之类的话。基本上，所有的野生动物都从树林里冲出来，把这个人撕成了碎片。随后，拜诺继续祈祷。回来后，他发现那其实是他的一个学生，一个叫阿尔海恩（Alherne）的家伙。拜诺当时处境糟糕透顶，
so do people still go there to get healed? Yeah brilliant, how many? lots of people? loads of people anyway of people loads of people yeah anyway just very very quickly because there's loads of there's loads of great stories about bano but actually my favorite one is basically he was really popular everyone wanted everyone wanted a bit of him you know in his monastery and all this sort so he needed a bit of time to pray
但幸运的是，他拥有让人死而复生的超能力。所以基本上，他只是四处走动，把那个人的所有碎块收集起来，重新拼凑在一起。他恢复正常了，但他找不到他的眉毛了。拜诺找不到阿尔海恩的一条眉毛了，它不见了。于是他环顾四周，心想：好吧。他手里有一根用来帮他从河里走出来的手杖，
so he what he used to do was he'd go out into the middle of a river and he had a rock and he'd kneel on the river to pray at night time anyway one night he was disturbed and he was he muttered something under his breath and obviously he's got a direct line to god so he said something like you know somebody should teach that person a lesson or something like that something to those effect and basically all of these wild animals came out of the woods and ripped this person to shreds and anyway beno beno just continued praying didn. Came back, and then he realised it was one of his pupils, a guy called Alhern. And he was, you know, Beinod was in an awful way,
手杖顶端是铁制的。于是他把手杖上的铁尖取下来，贴在阿尔海恩的额头上，把自己的另一条眉毛给了他。从那以后，这位圣阿尔海恩——他后来成了一名圣徒——就被称为“铁眉”。太棒了。所以他不是整形外科医生的主保圣人。不，只是生病的牛。
but luckily he has this power of bringing people back from the dead. So basically, he just went around and gathered all the bits of him and put them back together. And he was fine, but he couldn't find his eyebrow. Beinod couldn't find one of his eyebrows. It was missing. So what he did was he looked around and he said, oh, okay. So he had his staff that he used to help get him out of the river.
所以，是的。嗯，我觉得这也是一个很棒的故事。这是一个非常好的故事。而且，人们一直在担心教堂担心人们不去教堂，我是说，如果能有“复活”这个选项，那绝对是一个巨大的动力，对吧？但是，我是说，死而复生的选项难道不是基督教信仰的核心部分吗？对，完全如此。哦，多米尼克，别开你那些神学玩笑了。好吧，太棒了。所以这是第二个。好了。第三个。好吧，第三个。
And they had an iron tip. So he took the iron tip off his staff, stuck it onto Alherne's forehead, and gave him his other eyebrow. And from then on, this Saint Alherne, he became a saint, was known as Iron Eyebrow. Brilliant. So he's not the patron saint of plastic surgeons. No, just sick cattle.
这是一个大块头。我们留在北威尔士。这次我们要去北威尔士的兰弗罗辛的圣布罗斯芬教堂。这是……再说一遍。抱歉。北威尔士的兰弗罗辛的圣布罗斯芬教堂。这是……再说一遍，抱歉。圣布罗斯芬·兰弗罗辛。好吧，没关系，我只是确认一下。没关系。你觉得你可能知道吗，多米尼克？如果我知道的话……是的，我确实知道。好吧，很好。
So, yeah. Well, I think that's a great one as well. That's a very good one. And I mean, the whole thing people worrying about, you know, churches are worried that people aren't going to church. I mean, the option of being brought back to life, I mean, that would be incentive, wouldn't it? But, I mean, surely the option of being brought back to life
那座教堂——这也是一座我负责照看的教堂（作为“无主教堂之友”组织的一部分），但这是一座这样一个教堂：有一个人在他死后改变了历史的进程。你们俩知道一个叫罗伯特·罗伯茨（Robert Roberts）的人吗？不知道。好吧，我想你们也不知道。他是1888年北威尔士的一个采石场工人。谁？他。他。就是那个人。
is a key part of the Christian faith, isn't it? Yeah, exactly. Oh, Dominic, stop it with your theological jokes. OK, so that's brilliant. So that's two. All right. Number three. OK, three.
你是个历史学家。拜托。不管怎样，罗伯特·罗伯茨于1888年去世，他唯一的愿望就是被埋葬在他的女儿旁边。但他不是已建立的英格兰教会的成员。他是一个非国教徒。麻烦就是从这里开始的。有很多关于为什么这对他行不通的故事，但基本上……牧师不允许他把女儿葬在教堂里，葬在教堂旁边的墓地里。
Big one. We're staying in North Wales. This time we're going to St Brothyn's Llanfrothyn in North Wales. This is one... Say that again. Sorry. St Brothyn Llanfrothan in north wales this is say that again sorry saint brothan flanfrothan okay all right that's fine just checking that's fine did you think you might know what dominic if i did yeah i did exactly yeah okay fine and that one so this is this is a great church this
于是冲突的舞台就此搭好了。事情是这样的：罗伯特·罗伯茨的家人去找了一位刚刚拿到资格的年轻律师——你们绝对会认识这家伙，如果你们不认识罗伯特·罗伯茨的话——大卫·劳埃德·乔治（David Lloyd George）。你们听说过吗？哦，是的。哦，对，多米尼克的英雄。多米尼克爱大卫……好吧，抱歉，听起来我好像专门挑了多米尼克最喜欢的教堂。没关系，这本该如此。这不是故意的，但我很高兴把它包含进来。基本上，这场葬礼可以说是开启了大卫·劳埃德·乔治职业生涯的事件。他当时是一名刚获得资格的律师，年仅25岁，他接手了这个案子，并建议家属直接行动，
is one that i actually look after what's friend of the friendless churches but um this is a church where um uh there's one man and he basically changed the course of history after his death at this church so do either of you know a guy called robert roberts no no right okay i didn't think you did he was a northwellian quarry man in 1888. Who? Him. Him. That one.
违抗牧师，违抗教区。他建议家属直接行动，违抗牧师，违抗教区，把罗伯特·罗伯茨埋葬在女儿旁边的教堂——我是指威尔士教堂的墓地里。但牧师早就嗅到了风头，于是把墓地大门锁上了，所以他们进不去。但他们怎么做呢？在大卫·劳埃德·乔治的带领下，他们去了一座沿着弯弯曲曲的小路才能到达的极其偏远的小教堂，把遗体运到了那里。在大卫·劳埃德·乔治的带领下，他们砸开了墓地的大门，借着烛光和灯笼的光，将罗伯特·罗伯茨安葬在他的女儿身旁。一切都很美好，直到牧师发现这件事，随后爆发了一场巨大的诉讼案。陪审团投票支持罗伯茨家族，法官投票支持教会——
You're a historian. Come on. So anyway, Robert Roberts died 1888 and he wanted to be buried next to his daughter. That was his one wish. But his daughter, but he wasn't a member of the established Church of England. He was a nonconformist. And that's where all the trouble began there's loads of kind of story about why this didn't work out for him but basically um the vicar wouldn't allow him to be buried in the church next to his daughter in the churchyard next
不是投票，你们懂我意思。大卫·劳埃德·乔治将其上诉到高等法院并最终获胜。但这基本上开启了他的政治生涯，因为两年后他被选为卡那封郡的国会议员，然后他成为了……正如你所说，历史的余烬。哦，天哪。
to his daughter and the scene was sort of set for a clash um so how it all happens was uh kind of uh robert roberts family went to a newly qualified solicitor a guy you will know definitely you'll know this guy if you don't know robert roberts um david lloyd george have you heard oh yes oh yeah dominic's hero dominic loves david yeah okay sorry it sounds like i've sort of picked Dominic's best churches. That's all right. That's how it should be. That was unintentional, but I thought I'd get this in. So basically, this burial is sort of what launched David Lloyd George's career. So basically, he was a newly qualified solicitor. He was age 25, and he took up this case, and he advised the family to just go ahead,
干得漂亮。干得非常漂亮。以前有人这么做过吗？其实没有。真的吗？你是第一个。哦，好吧。我能问一下，女儿死后多久了？我们知道吗？哦，天哪。
defy the vicar, defy the diocese, and he advised the family to just go ahead defy the vicar divide defy the diocese and bury robert roberts next to his daughter in the church i mean church of wales um churchyard but the vicar knew this was kind of brewing so he locked up the churchyard and all of this and so they couldn't get in but what they did do led by david lloyd george they went to this really remote church down all of these winding lanes they brought the body down by david lloyd george they went to this really remote church down all of these winding lanes they brought the body down there david lloyd george broke open the churchyard gates and by candlelight and lanterns they buried robert roberts next to his daughter all lovely until the vicar found out then there was a huge court case the jury voted in favor of the Roberts family, the judge voted in favour of the church,
是一具正在腐烂的尸体吗？是一具正在腐烂的尸体，是的。绝对是的。所以这基本上是不同派别、威尔士异见人士与建制派教会之间的一场斗争，这在19世纪末、20世纪初其实是一个巨大的政治议题。我是说，现在完全被遗忘了。嗯，确实如此，不过所有这些事情……
not voted, you know what I mean, David Lord George appealed it at the High Court and eventually won. But that basically launched his career because then two years later he was voted the MP for Carnarvonshire and then he became, you know, the rest is history, as you might say. Oh, goodness.
没有投票，你知道我的意思，大卫·劳埃德·乔治向高等法院上诉并最终赢了。但那基本上开启了他的职业生涯，因为两年后他被选为卡纳芬郡的国会议员，然后他成为了……你知道的，正如你所说，接下来的历史就顺理成章了。哦，天哪。
Nicely done. Very nicely done. Has anyone ever done that before? They haven't, actually. Actually, no, you're the first. Oh, okay. Can I just ask, the daughter, how long had she been dead? Do we know? Oh, golly.
干得漂亮。干得非常漂亮。以前有人这么做过吗？其实没有。说实话，没有，你是第一个。哦，好吧。请问，那个女儿死了多久了？我们知道吗？哦，天哪。
Was it a kind of mouldering body? It was a mouldering body, yeah. Definitely, definitely, yeah. So this is basically a battle between dissenters, Welsh dissenters and the established church, which was a huge political issue actually in the late 19th, early 20th century. I mean, completely forgotten now. Well, exactly, but also all of this stuff.
那是一种正在腐烂的尸体吗？是的，是正在腐烂的尸体。绝对是的，绝对是的。所以这基本上是异见人士、威尔士异见人士与建制派教会之间的斗争，这在19世纪末20世纪初实际上是一个巨大的政治议题。我的意思是，现在完全被遗忘了。嗯，确实，但还有所有这些事情。
So, you know, David Lloyd George did, I mean, Lloyd George, I can probably just call him that. I don't need to give him his full name um uh but this case became sort of the catalyst for the establishment of the the church um in wales as well which um you know in which eventually happened in the 1920s so all of that sort of happened because because of this burial case which is really cool but just really quickly um the church is amazing too so saint brothan was a like sixth century saint it's the church is third now 13th century it's built on an uh right on the estuary um so right on the shore it's amazing 15th century roof massive timbers
所以，你知道，大衛·勞埃德·喬治確實，我的意思是，勞埃德·喬治，我大概可以直接叫他這個名字。我不需要說出他的全名，嗯，呃，不過這個案件可以說是威爾斯教會建立的催化劑，呃，你知道，這最終發生在 1920 年代，所以所有這些都是因為這起埋葬案而發生的，這真的很酷，不過話說回來，這座教堂本身也很棒，所以聖布羅坦（Saint Brothen）是一位大約六世紀的聖人，這座教堂現在是第 13 世紀的，它建在一處呃，就在河口上，所以就在岸邊，真的很棒，有 15 世紀的屋頂和巨大的木梁。
absolutely gorgeous definitely go and see it okay well so a landmark in the history of disestablishmentarianism yeah exactly which is definitely a word we've never had on the podcast before um and before we move from that area yeah i just have a fourth one we've got four no no no this is just kind of a little you know this is this is 3a um so if you're if you really like your uh prime ministers, which I know some of the listeners to this show should do, you should go and see St. Daniel's in Howarden in Finchshire, which is where Gladstone was married in 1839.
絕對美極了，一定要去看看。好吧，那麼，這是反國教運動（disestablishmentarianism）歷史上的地標。沒錯，這絕對是我們播客節目中從未出現過的一個詞，而在我們離開這個地區之前， yeah，我還有第四個，我們有四個，不，不，不，這只是一個小小的，你知道，這是 3a 部分，所以如果你真的很喜歡你的呃首相，我知道這節目的某些聽眾應該會喜歡，你應該去看看芬奇郡（Flintshire）霍華登（Hawarden）的聖丹尼爾教堂（St. Daniel's），格萊斯頓（Gladstone）就是在那裡於 1839 年結婚的。
Do you know this, Dominic? You're nodding. Yeah, Gladstone, Howarden. Yeah, of course. Fine. Grand. But apparently when they got married, the church was crammed to suffocation with females which you know some people might like um but uh anyway what's really interesting about this there's obviously that history but there's a memorial chapel to gladstone and the family commissioned gladstone's very good friend burn jones to design the window and it's an absolute i mean burn jones is great if you like him some people don't um but it's an absolute, I mean, Burne-Jones is great, if you like him. Some people don't.
你知道這個嗎，多米尼克（Dominic）？你在點頭。對，格萊斯頓，霍華登。對，當然。很好。太棒了。但據說他們結婚時，教堂裡擠滿了女性，你知道有些人可能會喜歡，不過，呃，無論如何，這裡真正有趣的是，除了那段歷史之外，還有一個紀念格萊斯頓的禮拜堂，他的家人生前委託格萊斯頓的好朋友伯恩-瓊斯（Burne-Jones）來設計窗戶，這絕對是一座，我是說，如果你喜歡伯恩-瓊斯的話，他真的很棒，有些人不喜歡，但這絕對是一座，我是說，伯恩-瓊斯真的很棒，如果你喜歡他的話。有些人不喜歡。
But it's an amazing window. It's a nativity scene. You know, it's massive, all beautiful, kind of beautiful Burne-Jones style. But yeah, definitely worth going to see. If you like Prime Ministers, Burne-Jones. Wow, we do. Yeah, we love it. Yeah, on this podcast, we love Burne-Jones, we love Prime Ministers. So that's absolutely ticking every box.
但這是一扇驚豔的窗戶。這是一個耶穌降生圖的場景。你知道的，它非常巨大，全部都很美麗，帶有一種美麗的伯恩-瓊斯風格。不過是的，絕對值得去看看。如果你喜歡首相們、伯恩-瓊斯。哇，我們確實喜歡。對，我們愛死它了。對，在這個播客節目裡，我們愛伯恩-瓊斯，我們愛首相們。所以這完全符合所有的要求。
And Rachel, we've been talking for half an hour, so I think should have a break really done you've done three i know you've got to get seven in so there's now huge jeopardy yeah will you be able to get your now seven into half an hour um guys don't go away yeah i'm not allowed to say that am i dominic because you it sounds appealing but but i mean this is so exciting well no one would want to go away because it is so exciting can you get seven Can you get seven into half an hour? Can you get seven into half an hour? Definitely not. In a minute find out. Bye bye. Bye.
雷切爾（Rachel），我們已經聊了半個小時了，所以我覺得真的該休息一下了。你已經介紹了三個。我知道你得湊齊七個，所以現在壓力巨大。 yeah，你能在半個小時內把剩下的七個都介紹完嗎？ yeah，大家別走開。 yeah，我不能這麼說，對吧，多米尼克，因為聽起來很吸引人，但，我的意思是，這太令人興奮了。好吧，沒人會想走開，因為這實在是太令人興奮了。你能塞進七個嗎？你能把七個塞進半小時內嗎？你能把七個塞進半小時內嗎？絕對不行。過一會兒見分曉。拜拜。拜拜。
I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman and together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our members club if you want ad-free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets head to therestisentertainment.com. That's
我是瑪麗娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查·奧斯曼（Richard Osman），我們共同主持《這就是娛樂》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。這是你每週必看的娛樂新聞、評論、八卦猛料，在我們的問答環節中，我們將拉開娛樂圈的帷幕，告訴你這一切是如何運作的。我們剛剛推出了會員俱樂部，如果你想要無廣告收聽、額外單集以及提前獲得現場門票，請前往 therestisentertainment.com。也就是
therestisentertainment.com. Welcome back to The Rest Is History. We are facing a half an hour of intense excitement and jeopardy as our guest, Rachel Morley, the director of Friends of Friends Churches, former winner of Person of the Year, is going to see if she can fit her remaining seven churches into the last half hour of the show, having taken the first half hour to do three churches. It's massive massive isn't it
therestisentertainment.com。歡迎回到《這就是歷史》（The Rest Is History）。我們正面臨著半小時緊張刺激與巨大壓力的挑戰，我們的嘉賓、關愛教堂之友（Friends of Friends Churches）總監、前年度人物得主雷切爾·莫利（Rachel Morley），將看看她是否能在節目的最後半小時裡，塞進她剩下的七座教堂，此前她已經花了前半小時介紹了三座教堂。這真是太巨大、太巨大了，不是嗎？
it's a high octane i mean this is unbelievable at its best okay so neither of you talk for the next half an hour please okay so and i'll just get it out fine okay next number four on my list uh oh i have i have a big intro to this because i want to try and fit as many churches in as possible so i'm just going to try my best okay right anyway who knows about commonwealth grace commission yeah i do i've been to it well done anyway okay there's a book there's a really good book that came out i think last year the year before called tomb with a view by peter ross he's got a great chapter in it uh and he told me lots about commonwealth grace commission that i didn't realize so things like uh if you're buried in a commonwealth grave cemetery your your stone has to be 813 millimeters above the grass and
這簡直是高辛烷值，我的意思是，這絕對是巔峰狀態。好吧，接下來的半小時請你們倆都別說話，拜拜。好吧，那我就直接說好了。好吧，我清單上的第四個——哦，我對這個有一個很長的開場白，因為我想盡可能多塞進一些教堂，所以我要盡力而為。好吧，對吧。不管怎樣，誰知道聯邦戰爭墳墓委員會（Commonwealth War Graves Commission）？ yeah，我知道，我去過。幹得好。好吧，有一本書，去年或前年出了一本非常好的書，叫《帶著風景的墳墓》（Tomb with a View），作者是彼得·羅斯（Peter Ross），他在裡面寫了一個很棒的章節，他告訴了我很多關於聯邦戰爭墳墓委員會我以前不知道的事，比如，如果你葬在聯邦戰爭墳墓公墓裡，你的墓碑必須高出草地 813 毫米，然後
the grass has to be cut between 3.5 and 6 centimeters I thought that was very interesting anyway this is kind of a segue into number four which is a world war churches chapels memorial churches chapels so I want to call out just two which would be very familiar, and I'm not going to have time to talk about them in any great depth, despite I've written loads. There's the Italian Chapel on Orkney, which is great. It's a prisoner of war, double Nissen huts.
草必須修剪在 3.5 到 6 公分之間。我覺得這非常有趣。不管怎樣，這算是引出第四個，也就是世界大戰時期的教堂、禮拜堂、紀念教堂和禮拜堂。所以我只想點出其中兩個大家會非常熟悉的，雖然我沒有時間深入探討，儘管我寫了大量的內容。奧克尼群島（Orkney）上有義大利小教堂（Italian Chapel），非常棒。這是一個戰俘營，由兩個雙尼森小屋（Nissen huts）改建而成的。
They used cement. They used things like corned beef tins to make candle holders and car exhaust to make the font. Really great. Rachel, let me interrupt interrupt one of our listeners suggested this kimberl kind of rufod kimru fod he suggested it so give yourself a massive round of applause yes great anyway moving on from that um there's a wales place of work there's a wales prisoner of war uh chapel which many people don't know about it's Hentland chapel near the River Tyvie that was a 1994 chapel again sorry 1944 chapel it's again it's a Nissen hut and they used all sorts of
他們用水泥。他們用像是鹹牛肉罐頭來做燭臺，用汽車排氣管來做洗禮盤。真的很棒。雷切爾，打斷一下，打斷一下，我們的一位聽眾建議這個……（威爾斯語）kind of rufod（威爾斯語），他建議了這個，所以給自己鼓個大掌吧。 yeah，太棒了。不管怎樣，繼續，呃，威爾斯有一個工作場所，有一個威爾斯戰俘禮拜堂，許多人並不知道它，那是靠近蒂維河（River Teifi）的亨特蘭禮拜堂（Hentland chapel），那是 1994 年的禮拜堂，再次抱歉，是 1944 年的禮拜堂，它同樣是一個尼森小屋，他們使用了各種各樣的
things like berries tea coffee they burned fish or boiled fish bones to make glue and they decorated that's all great i have to go at really high speed so number four neither of those was number four no no those were those were just ones that deserve a mention they deserve a mention but they're not number four so number four it's probably one of the most moving places i've ever been in my whole entire life um it's the sandon memorial Chapel in Hampshire. Outside it's a really modest kind of red brick chapel but inside it is just I mean it's it's just this epic large-scale murals. The interior is
東西，像是漿果、茶葉、咖啡，他們燒魚骨或煮魚骨來製作膠水，然後進行裝飾。這些都很棒。我得用極高的速度進行，所以第四個——那兩座都不是第四個？不，不，那些只是值得一提的。它們值得一提，但不是第四個。所以第四個，可能是我整個人生中去過的最感人的地方之一，呃，那是漢普郡（Hampshire）的桑德姆紀念禮拜堂（Sandham Memorial Chapel）。從外面看，它是一個非常朴素的紅磚禮拜堂，但內部簡直是——我是說，它簡直是史詩般的大型壁畫。內部完全由
entirely painted by Stanley Spencer and it was done between 1920 and 1926 and it was built to honour the forgotten dead of World War I specifically Lieutenant Harry Sandham who basically he was on the Salonica front with Spencer he came back from the war but he died from he caught malaria they think while he was out there and he died once he came back but he doesn't appear on any official kind of list or anything because he wasn't kind of you know one of the the
斯坦利·斯賓塞（Stanley Spencer）繪製，創作於 1920 年到 1926 年之間，是為了紀念第一次世界大戰中被遺忘的陣亡將士而建的，特別是哈里·桑德姆中尉（Lieutenant Harry Sandham），他基本上曾與斯賓塞一起在薩洛尼卡前線（Salonica front），他從戰爭中生還，但死於他在那裡感染的瘧疾，他們認為他是因為在那裡感染了瘧疾，回來後就去世了，但他沒有出現在任何官方名單或類似的東西上，因為他並不是那種，你知道的，官方的
official warden exactly great thanks Dominic anyway what's great about this is so it seems from so Stanley Spencer he worked as an orderly in Beaufort Hospital in Bristol and then he was out on the Salonika front
陣亡軍人之一。沒錯，太棒了，謝謝多米尼克。不管怎樣，這個地方最棒的地方在於，斯賓塞曾作為護理員在布里斯託的博福特醫院（Beaufort Hospital）工作，然後他去了薩洛尼卡前線，
and basically they're a series of paintings so it shows his um his time in the hospital working in the hospital so it's like filling tea urns changing the beds doing the laundry um all of that sort of thing uh and then above you've got um scenes from um for scenes from Salonika and it's I mean it's so moving he painted himself into it so he's you know he's cooking rashers there's a dog licking out an empty Frebentos tin there's I mean but it's
基本上這是一系列畫作，展示了他呃在醫院裡工作、在醫院裡服務的時光——所以就像是灌滿茶水壺、鋪床、洗衣服，所有這類事情；然後在上方，你有呃來自薩洛尼卡的場景，這——我是說，太感人了。他把自己畫進了畫裡，所以你看，他在煎培根，有一隻狗在舔空法本托斯（Frebentos）罐頭，這——我是說，它
it's so it's just so powerful because of the scale that they're on and then I have to miss out so much because I have no time but anyway the east wall is this resurrection scene and it's not like any other resurrection scene you will ever see it's basically um uh the in the center there's a carriage and the it's broken apart it's split apart there's bits of wood flying everywhere there are two horses which have collapsed right in the middle and it's just a chaotic scene right
太震撼了，因為它的規模實在宏大。然後我不得不遺漏掉這麼多，因為我沒有時間了。不過不管怎樣，東牆是這幅復活場景，它與你見過的任何其他復活場景都不同。它基本上是，呃，在中心有一輛馬車，它碎裂了開來，裂成了兩半，到處都是飛濺的木頭碎片，正中間有兩匹倒地的馬，這是一個非常混亂的場景，就在
in the foreground and it's all of these men who are getting out of their graves and they're picking up their white crosses and they're walking towards a figure barely decipherable in the kind of background and it's a little white figure of christ he's tiny and they're walking up and they're giving their crosses to christ and after that they walk past him and into kind of a peaceful landscape, which is Watership Down, which is near where the chapel is located. Watership Down as in the rabbits? As in rabbits. Yeah, but also it's a place, it's a real place.
前景中，全都是這些從墳墓裡爬出來的人，他們拿起自己的白色十字架，朝著背景中一個幾乎難以辨認的人物走去，那是基督微小的白色身影，他非常微小，他們走上前去，把十字架交給基督，在那之後，他們從他身邊走過，進入了一個平靜的風景中，那是水鄉船底（Watership Down），就在禮拜堂所在地附近。「水鄉船底」，是指那些兔子嗎？是指兔子。 yeah，但這也是一個地方，一個真實存在的地方。
So anyway, so that's absolutely amazing. But what was really terrible about this was when they came to consecrate the chapel, all the various bishops said they wouldn't consecrate it because it showed animals being resurrected. So the horses were kind of coming back to life and the dogs and stuff like that. And they said, animals don't have souls, so we're not going to resurrect it. Eventually, the Bishop of Guildford said he would consecrate the chapel, but only if they put curtains and stuff over the animals. My God, that's very harsh. Isn't it bonkers? Anyway, that is one of the most...
所以不管怎樣，這絕對是令人驚嘆的。但真正糟糕的是，當他們來為禮拜堂行奉獻禮時，所有各地的主教都說他們不會為其奉獻，因為它描繪了動物的復活。所以馬匹之類的活了過來，還有狗之類的。他們說，動物沒有靈魂，所以我們不會讓它們復活。最後，吉爾福德主教（Bishop of Guildford）表示他願意為禮拜堂行奉獻禮，但前提是他們必須用窗簾之類的東西把動物遮起來。我的天啊，這太嚴苛了。這不是很瘋狂嗎？不管怎樣，這簡直是其中最……
I haven't done it justice. Animals definitely have souls. It's completely bonkers. Spencer did this before Cookham and all that? Yes, yes. So Cookham is what he called a little suburb of heaven. There's all that kind of amazing stuff coming out of the graves. Exactly, exactly.
我簡直無法公正地形容它。動物絕對有靈魂。這簡直完全瘋狂。斯賓塞是在庫克姆（Cookham）以及所有那些事情之前畫的嗎？對，對。所以庫克姆被他稱為天堂的小郊區。那種從墳墓裡出來的驚人場景應有盡有。沒錯，沒錯。
No, it's just, it's one of the... Yeah, it's just one of those. Sorry, I will just say there's one scene in it where it's in the hospital and they're meant to be disinfecting the bedside lockers. So they've got these copper baths and there's a man kind of, you know, putting them into the thing. But Stanley Spencer was really small. He was like five foot two and weighed less than seven stone and he couldn't
不，這就是——它是其中一個…… yeah，它是其中之一。抱歉，我只想說，其中有一個場景是在醫院裡，他們本該消毒床頭櫃。所以他們有這些銅浴盆，有一個人正在把東西放進去，但斯坦利·斯賓塞個子非常矮。他大概五英尺二英寸（約 157 公分），體重不到七英石（約 44 公斤），他實際上無法
actually physically lift the um lockers into the bath to do the work and he paints himself into it and he's crouching he's hiding between the two baths and trying to kind of get away from it all um and it's just oh sorry I have no it sounds I'm thinking about it it's one of it's just yeah people more people should know about it it's so wonderful well thank you that's amazing
把那些櫃子親手抬進浴盆裡去清洗，於是他把自己也畫了進去，他蹲著，藏在兩個浴盆之間，試圖逃避这一切，這簡直——哦，抱歉，我沒有——回想起來，這簡直是——是的，應該有更多人知道它，它是如此美妙。好吧，謝謝，這太驚人了。
all right number five okay this is a very quick one this was meant to be my number five and my breaking point because I wanted to sing a little song at the end of it oh my god
好了，第五個。好吧，這個非常快。這本來應該是我的第五個也是我的崩潰點，因為我本想在它結束時唱一小首歌。哦，我的天啊。
you can't miss out on the song you can still do that all right okay just very very quickly so number five is St Nicholas's Worth in Sussex. So this is a...
你不能錯過這首歌，你還是可以唱的。好吧，好吧，非常非常快地——所以第五個是蘇塞克斯郡（Sussex）的沃斯聖尼古拉教堂（St Nicholas's Worth）。所以這是一個……
It was once in a clearing of a forest. It's the largest Saxon cruciform church that still survives on its original foundations. The forest is now cleared and the church is sort of squeezed between the M23 and a housing estate in Crawley. But it is one of... I know, Dominic, you're makingley. But it is one of, like, I know Dominic you're making faces, but it is actually, like, it's one of the most important and ancient churches.
它曾經位於一片森林的空地上。這是至今仍在原底座上存留的最大的撒克遜十字形教堂。這片森林現在已經被砍伐，教堂被夾在了 M23 高速公路和克勞利（Crawley）的一個住宅區之間。但它確實是——我知道，多米尼克，你在做鬼臉。但它確實是，像是——我知道多米尼克你在做鬼臉，但它實際上——它是最重要、最古老的教堂之一。
Somebody once described it as the most beautiful set of arches left to us by the Saxon world, which is great. Sounds good. Yeah. Anyway, interesting things about this is all the Saxon stuff, obviously, but in the churchyard you will find Robert Whitehead who does anybody know who he was?
有人曾把它描述為撒克遜世界留給我們最美的一組拱門，這很棒。聽起來不錯。 yeah。不管怎樣，關於這個地方有趣的事是所有的撒克遜遺跡，很顯然，但在教堂墓地裡你會找到羅伯特·懷特黑德（Robert Whitehead）——有沒有人知道他是誰？
no Tom he was the inventor of the torpedo oh that's a good fact it is a good fact and basically he sold his first torpedoes to the Austrians and then in 1912 his granddaughter went to like I don't know, not launch torpedoes, that would be terrible, to celebrate a new torpedo or something in Austria.
不，湯姆。他是魚雷的發明者。哦，這是一個很好的事實。這確實是一個很好的事實，基本上他把他的第一批魚雷賣給了奧地利人，然後在 1912 年，他的孫女去到——我不知道，不是去發射魚雷，那樣太可怕了——去奧地利慶祝一場新魚雷的試驗之類的。
And she met the commander, who was George von Trapp, and she went on to marry him. They had seven children in 12 years. Then she died, and the husband got a move to salzburg hired a nun and needed a nanny who needed a nanny got a nun called maria and then they became the van trapp family choir and they there's a sound of music that is a very very good story that is a good story and i can see why you need a song well no i'm not going to sing the sound of music but basically there's so much saxon stuff about this so it's saxon arches saxon foundation saxon apps saxon windows i don't know if this is right but i i like to make up songs dominic will know this is
然後她遇到了指揮官，也就是格奧爾格·馮·特拉普（George von Trapp），她隨後嫁給了他。他們在 12 年裡生了七個孩子。然後她去世了，丈夫搬到了薩爾斯堡，雇了一位修女，需要一個保姆——需要一個保姆，於是雇了一位名叫瑪麗亞（Maria）的修女，然後他們變成了特拉普家族合唱團（Trapp family choir），他們有了《音樂之聲》（The Sound of Music）。這真是一個非常非常好的故事。這確實是個好故事，我能理解為什麼你需要一首歌了。好吧，不，我不會唱《音樂之聲》，但基本上，這裡有太多撒克遜時期的東西了，所以有撒克遜拱門、撒克遜地基、撒克遜後殿、撒克遜窗戶。我不知道這對不對，但我喜歡現編歌曲，多米尼克會知道這在我們家裡
sort of a thing in our family and we like to make up random songs i think so i'm always making up songs tom so if i if i could give saint nicholas worth a song, I would call it... Sorry, I feel so embarrassed now, but anyway. I'm too Saxon for my shirt. Too Saxon for my shirt. So Saxon it hurts. Anyway, there we go. We've never had someone singing on the podcast throughout the Anglo-Saxons before.
算是常態，我們喜歡即興創作隨機的歌曲，我想是的，所以我一直在即興編歌，湯姆，所以如果我能為沃斯的聖尼古拉教堂創作一首歌，我會把它叫做——抱歉，我現在覺得好尷尬，但不管怎樣。我太撒克遜了，以至於襯衫都穿不下。（Too Saxon for my shirt.）太撒克遜了，甚至讓人感到心痛。不管怎樣，就是這樣。我們以前從未在播客節目中有過嘉賓在介紹盎格魯-撒克遜人時唱歌。
But I think we should make it a rule. Anyway, there we go. We have to move on. Sorry, guys. Is that the only song? That's the only song. Sorry. Oh, I'm disappointed.
但我覺得我們應該把它定為一條規矩。不管怎樣，就是這樣。我們得繼續前進了。抱歉，各位。這就是唯一的一首歌嗎？這就是唯一的一首歌。抱歉。哦，我好失望。
Sorry, sorry. I mean, who knows? I might come up against anything else. Spontaneously. The next one is Time and Space Church. Dominic, I know you like this. Sorry, Tom, you might like this too. I feel like I'm kind of leaving you out. Sorry. Anyway. No, no. You focus on Dominic I know you like this sorry Tom you might like this too I feel like I'm kind of leaving you out
抱歉，抱歉。我的意思是，誰知道呢？我可能會即興遇到其他什麼東西。下一個是「時間與空間教堂」（Time and Space Church）。多米尼克，我知道你喜歡這個。抱歉，湯姆，你可能也會喜歡這個。我覺得我有點把你冷落了。抱歉。不管怎樣。不，不。你專注於多米尼克，我知道你喜歡這個。抱歉，湯姆，你可能也會喜歡這個。我覺得我有點把你冷落了。
sorry anyway you focus on Dominic he needs education he does need education yes anyway so Dominic I know you did a series or a programme on sci-fi didn't you a series Rach a series a whole series I thought it was just one off oh well
抱歉。不管怎樣，你專注於多米尼克，他需要接受教育。他確實需要接受教育。沒錯。不管怎樣，多米尼克，我知道你曾做過一個關於科幻小說的系列節目或是一個節目，對吧？一個系列，雷切爾，一個系列，整整一個系列。我以為那只是一次性的節目。哦，好吧。
it's a great series if anybody would like to watch it Tomorrow's World. Tomorrow's World, there we go. The unearthly history of science fiction. Anyway, so I don't know if you mentioned this because I don't actually remember if I watched the programme. But first of all, I want to go to St John the Baptist Whitbourne in Herefordshire.
這是一個很棒的系列節目，如果有人想看的話——《明日世界》（Tomorrow's World）。《明日世界》，就是這樣。《科幻小說的非凡歷史》（The unearthly history of science fiction）。不管怎樣，所以不知道你是否提到過這個，因為我實際上不記得我是否看過那個節目。但首先，我要去赫里福德郡（Herefordshire）的懷特本聖約翰巴蒂斯特教堂（St John the Baptist Whitbourne）。
Weirdly, we didn't mention that in our science fiction series. Well, Dominic, that is a huge oversight on your part because at the end of the 17th century, that is when Francis Goodwin, the Bishop of Herefordshire,
奇怪的是，我們在科幻小說系列裡沒有提到那個。好吧，多米尼克，那是你的一個巨大疏忽，因為在 17 世紀末，那是赫里福德郡的主教弗朗西斯·古德溫（Francis Goodwin），
he was living next to the church and he wrote the world's first science fiction novel, The Man on the Moon. Very good. The Man in the Moon. You didn't know that?
他當時住在教堂旁邊，寫出了世界上第一部科幻小說——《月球上的人》（The Man on the Moon）。非常好。《月球上的人》（The Man in the Moon）。你不知道這個？
Get the title right. The Man in the Moon. The Man in the Moon. Anyway, basically, very quickly, it's a Spanish man man called domingo gonzalez he's stranded on an island and he trains a flock of swans to um uh to basically uh what's the word i'm looking for to basically fly him away in a cart and they fly him up to the moon and when he gets to the moon or when he's on his way to the moon he realizes that actually copernicus was right that the uh the earth is not the center of the universe and it revolves around the sun and when did he write this at the end of the 17th century right very very end of the 17th century
把書名弄對。《月球上的人》（The Man in the Moon）。《月球上的人》（The Man in the Moon）。不管怎樣，基本上，非常快地說，這是一個名叫多明戈·岡薩雷斯（Domingo Gonzales）的西班牙人，他被困在一個荒島上，他訓練了一群天鵝，嗯，呃，基本上——我找的詞是什麼——基本上讓它們用一輛推車載著他飛走，它們把他載到了月球上。當他到達月球時，或者說在去月球的路上，他意識到哥白尼其實是正確的，地球並不是宇宙的中心，而是繞著太陽旋轉的。他是在什麼時候寫下這本書的？在 17 世紀末，對吧？非常非常接近 17 世紀末的時期。
and he also describes gravity gravity which is decades before isaac newton would ever go on to discover it godwin's buried in the church out in whitburn that's not the church this is again just the same oh god that's not even the church it's notburn. That's not the church. This is again just a segue. Oh God, that's not even the church. It's not the church, it's not the church. Anyway. There's so little time. No, no, no.
而且他還描述了重力——重力，這比艾薩克·牛頓（Isaac Newton）發現重力早了幾十年。古德溫被埋葬在懷特本的教堂墓地裡。那不是教堂，這又只是一個過渡。哦，天哪，那甚至不是教堂！不是懷特本。那不是教堂。這又只是一個過渡。哦，天哪，那甚至不是教堂！不是教堂，不是教堂。不管怎樣。時間太少了。不，不，不。
You keep doing these segues. So little time, but so many churches. Anyway, then, so we talked about Isaac Newton. From there, we go to St. Peter's and Paul
你一直在搞這些過渡。時間太少，但教堂太多。不管怎樣，然後，我們談到了艾薩克·牛頓。從那裡，我們前往拉特蘭（Rutland）的市場奧弗頓（Market Overton）的聖彼得與聖保羅教堂（St. Peter's and Paul）。
and Market Overton in Rutland. Basically, Isaac Newton's mother was from there. He spent a lot of time there. The church at Market Overton has lots of lovely Saxon elements and in the churchyard they discovered a bronze Saxon water clock something that was developed or derived from the ancient Egyptians
基本上，艾薩克·牛頓的母親就來自那裡。他在那裡度過了很長時間。市場奧弗頓的教堂有很多可愛的撒克遜元素，在教堂墓地裡，他們發現了一個青銅的撒克遜水鐘，這是一種從古埃及人那裡發展或演變而來的東西。
Newton was fascinated by this and it spurred on his studies and experiments into time and space and apparently there's a sundial on the church. And he donated it to the church in kind of gratitude for it kind of spurring on his studies. Anyway, the church that I want to talk about, which is actually number six. Neither of those were the church. No, no, no. Unbelievable.
牛頓對此著迷不已，這激發了他對時間和空間的研究與實驗，據說教堂裡還有一個日晷。他把它捐贈給了教堂，以此感謝它激發了自己的研究。不管怎樣，我要談論的教堂，實際上是第六個。那些都不是教堂。不，不，不。難以置信。
No, no, no. Anyway, but there's so many good churches. But basically, it's St. Gregory's, Kirkdale in Yorkshire. I think somebody definitely mentioned this on your list. I'm pretty certain. So above that church, you will find a preserved Saxon sundial. Oh, yes. Yes.
不，不，不。不管怎樣，但有這麼多好教堂。但基本上，它是約克郡（Yorkshire）的克克代爾聖格雷戈里教堂（St. Gregory's, Kirkdale）。我想肯定有人在你的清單上提到過這個。我非常確信。所以在那個教堂上方，你會發現一個保存完好的撒克遜日晷。哦，是的。是的。
That's wonderful. That is a good one. Great. I'm glad you know it. Yes. And it's next to where William Buckland found the hyena bones in the cave. That's correct. Oh, Tom. Tom, you're ruining my ending. Oh, I'm sorry. Oh, sorry, Rachel. Sorry.
那太棒了。那確實是一個好東西。太好了。我很高興你知道它。是的。它就在威廉·巴克蘭（William Buckland）在洞穴裡發現鬣狗骨頭的地方旁邊。沒錯。哦，湯姆。湯姆，你毀了我的結尾。哦，我很抱歉。哦，抱歉，雷切爾。抱歉。
It's fine. It's fine. No, but I love that church. Okay, that's good. But you know that there's like a, it's got like the longest inscription in Saxon English on that sundial. Do you know it? Do you know what it says? I can't remember, but I do i do remember no he doesn't remember okay great so i'll read it out to you very quickly so it says orm the son of gammel bought saint gregory's church when it was utterly broke and fallen and caused to be made anew from the ground he dedicated to christ and saint gregory in the days of king ed Edward and the days of Earl Trosty. Haworth bought me and Harith wrought me and brand the prior. So from that you can date the sundial to about 1055, 1065-ish,
沒關係。沒關係。不，但我愛死那座教堂了。好吧，那很好。但你知道嗎，在那座日晷上有一段——它上面有撒克遜英語中最長的銘文。你知道嗎？你知道上面寫的是什麼嗎？我不記得了，但我確實——我確實記得。不，他不記得。好吧，太好了，那我就非常快速地為你讀出來。上面寫著：當加姆爾（Gammel）的兒子奧姆（Orm）買下聖格雷戈里教堂時，它已經徹底破敗倒塌，他從地基開始讓人將其重建，他在愛德華國王（King Edward）和托斯蒂伯爵（Earl Trosty）在位期間，將其奉獻給基督和聖格雷戈里。霍沃思（Haworth）買下了我，哈里思（Harith）打造了我，還有修道院長布蘭德（Brand）。所以從中你可以把這個日晷的年代定在大約 1055 年、1065 年左右，
when Edward the Confessor was king, right? That's all great. Tosty is better known as Tostig the brother of my cat the name of my cat there you oh great yeah lovely and it all connects it all connects it all connects but basically then tosti um was killed uh he kills the gamal in that inscription and then eventually he was himself killed at uh stanford bridge yeah basically but the sundial is great it's um it was covered it remains in such good condition because it was um plastered over for about 700 years and was only discovered in 1771 but remarkably it's actually the sundial is a reused grave slab so when the when orm son of gammel says in this inscription
那是懺悔者愛德華（Edward the Confessor）為國王的時期，對吧？這一切都很棒。托斯蒂（Tosty）更為人所知的名字是托斯蒂格（Tostig），也就是我的貓的兄弟——我貓的名字。瞧，這就連上了，太棒了，這一切都連起來了，這一切都連起來了。但基本上，後來托斯蒂被殺了——他在那段銘文裡殺了加姆爾，然後最終他自己也在斯坦福橋之戰（Stanford Bridge）中被殺。 yeah，基本上，但日晷真的很棒，它——它被覆蓋著，之所以能保持如此完好的狀態，是因為它被灰泥封住了大約 700 年，直到 1771 年才被發現。但值得注意的是，實際上這個日晷是一塊被重複使用的墓碑，所以當加姆爾的兒子奧姆在這段銘文中
that he the old church was broken down they reused bits of that much earlier church which 20th century excavations found to be um about eighth or ninth century which is really cool so they found like carvings and stuff like that in the walls um and yeah there's loads of lovely cross slabs and all of that sort of stuff in the in the walls which is great anyway that's right about buckland quarry man 1821 i think yes um found uh nearby from there uh reopened a cave stone age things hyena bones but also um hippopotamus bones and it is yeah okay tom you okay, Tom, you know what. Yeah, yeah, no, and it's such a kind of dramatic setting. Yeah, absolutely.
說舊教堂已經倒塌時，他們重複使用了那座更早期的教堂的碎塊，20世紀的考古發掘發現那大約是 8 世紀或 9 世紀的，這真的很酷。所以他們在牆壁裡發現了像是雕刻之類的東西，對吧，牆壁裡有大量可愛的十字架墓碑以及所有這些東西，這真的很棒。不管怎樣，這與巴克蘭採石工人（Buckland quarry man）有關，大約是 1821 年吧，是的，在附近重新開啟了一個石器時代的洞穴，發現了鬣狗骨頭，還有河馬骨頭，確實是——好吧，湯姆，你知道的。 yeah， yeah，不，這真的是一個非常戲劇性的環境。 yeah，絕對的。
Go down from the church down and... Yeah, it's fabulous. Yes. All right, let's crack on. What are you on now, number eight? Number seven. Number seven. Oh, my God.
從教堂往下走，然後…… yeah，太美妙了。是的。好了，我們繼續趕進度。你現在到第幾個了，第八個？第七個。第七個。哦，我的天啊。
This is a quick one. Okay, this is weird animals to weird animals, sort of. So hippopotamuses to turkeys great okay so um most people think of churches they think of christmas that's definitely what the church of england and stats will tell us anyway but also there's a yorkshire church that celebrates not only the coming of christ but also the coming of the turkey does anybody know what saint andrews boynton in yorkshire no i don't know okay. It's a gorgeous church but there are turkeys everywhere in the church and the reason is because William Strickland of Boynton,
這個很快。好吧，這是奇怪的動物到奇怪的動物，某種程度上。所以從河馬到火雞，太棒了，好吧，大多數人一想到教堂，就會想到聖誕節，英國國教會的統計數據也絕對會這麼告訴我們。但除此之外，約克郡還有一座教堂，它不僅慶祝基督的降臨，還慶祝火雞的到來。有沒有人知道約克郡博因頓的聖安德魯教堂（St Andrew's Boynton）？不，我不知道。好吧。這是一座華麗的教堂，但教堂裡到處都是火雞，原因是因為博因頓的威廉·斯特里克蘭（William Strickland），
he bought the first turkey to Britain. So in 1526 he went to America to find his fortune. He went looking for gold but came back with six turkeys. Basically he bred them and then he sold them and they became so popular he became really rich he was able to build a country house he became an mp in the reign of queen elizabeth um but he adopted the turkey as his kind of family symbol so there's a turkey lectern there's turkeys in the window there's turkeys all over the tombs it's great. So first turkey came from him. And also when he was trying to get his coat of arms, he used the turkey.
他把第一隻火雞帶到了英國。所以大選 1526 年，他去美洲尋求財富。他去找黃金，卻帶回了六隻火雞。基本上他飼養了它們，然後把它們賣掉，它們變得如此受歡迎，以至於他變得非常富有，能夠建造一座鄉村別墅，並在伊麗莎白女王統治時期成為了一名國會議員。但他把火雞作為自己家族的象徵，所以教堂裡有一個火雞講道台，窗戶上有火雞，墓碑上到處都是火雞，這太棒了。所以第一隻火雞就是他帶來的。而且當他試圖獲得自己的紋章時，他也使用了火雞。
And his little sketch of a turkey is the earliest depiction of a turkey in the whole of Europe. That's fantastic. What a claim to fame. And why shouldn't turkeys be in churches? Why shouldn't they be in churches? They're God's creatures. That's right, yeah.
他畫的火雞小草圖是整個歐洲最早對火雞的描繪。這太 fantastique（太棒了）了。這真是一個巨大的名聲。為什麼火雞不能出現在教堂裡？它們為什麼不能出現在教堂裡？它們是上帝的造物。沒錯，是的。
But also, as old as a turkey is, the church is absolutely gorgeous. Inside, it's like a Georgian box. Beautiful. Redesigned by John Carr of York in the 18th century. Green panelled pews. It's got clustered columns, cornice, plaster puttees, swags, medallions. It's got this flourish of a staircase. Absolutely gorgeous.
但除此之外，正如火雞一樣古老，這座教堂也絕對美極了。內部就像一個喬治王時期的盒子。非常美麗。由約克的約翰·卡爾（John Carr of York）在 18世紀重新設計。綠色鑲板長椅。它有成束的柱子、檐口、石膏小天使、花環、紀念章。它擁有華麗的樓梯。絕對美極了。
And my favourite is a really lovely Norman tub font where it's got intersecting arches, kind of little, almost kind of classical capitals and plinths on the arches. And it's kind of got this greenish tinge and it's absolutely lovely. Loads more to say about that, but we have no time. Okay.
而我最喜歡的是一個非常可愛的諾曼式桶形洗禮盤，上面有交錯的拱門，幾乎帶有某種古典柱頭和拱門上的柱基。它帶有一種微綠的色調，非常可愛。關於這個還有很多可說的，但我們沒有時間了。好吧。
So we've got two left. Three left. Oh, we have three left. Oh my goodness. Okay, I'm going to be really quick. I'll try you've got 10 minutes oh okay the next one is a long one okay so so this this is kind of all this is so exciting for the listeners finding out whether you're going to do it or not okay let me just look at the time fine 15 minutes okay fine 10 10 all right tom i get it fine um so the next thing is all about like superstitions and magic and churches so
所以我們還剩兩個。還剩三個。哦，我們還剩三個。哦，天哪。好吧，我要非常快。我會試試——你還有 10 分鐘。哦，好吧，下一個很長，好吧。所以——這個有點——這對聽眾來說太令人興奮了，想知道你到底能不能完成。好吧，讓我看看時間。好吧，15 分鐘，好吧。 10，10。好吧，湯姆，我懂了，好吧。那麼，接下來的事情全是關於迷信、魔法和教堂的，所以
first of all i want to just give a mention to this is not the church by the way i want to give a mention to saint cadfins in gwynedd which is it's got a crying night it's a 13th uh 1350s effigy and basically apparently the knight has been crying for about 650 years but but uh there's like water dripping out of his right eye all the time this is my right eye um uh but somebody did some research and actually it's a fault in the stone there's well there's there's there's the very similar thing at bartholomew the great oh right okay yeah where there where there was somebody who was crying and then they fixed the drains and it stopped. Yeah, it's pretty much that sort of thing,
首先，我只想提一下——順便說一句，這不是那座教堂——我想提一下圭內斯（Gwynedd）的聖卡德芬教堂（St Cadfan's），那裡有一個哭泣的騎士，這是一個 13 世紀、1350 年代的雕像，據說這位騎士已經哭了約 650 年，嗯，呃，他的右眼一直在往下滴水——這是我的右眼，嗯，呃，但有人做了一些研究，實際上那是石頭的一個裂縫。嗯，還有，倫敦的大聖巴塞爾羅繆教堂（St Bartholomew the Great）也有非常類似的情況，哦，對吧， yeah，那裡曾經有一個人一直在哭泣，然後他們修理了排水溝，它就停了。 yeah，差不多就是那種情況，
which is sad. From there, a really popular church is St. Issue, Patricio and Powys where there's a kind of a rusty painted skeleton on the west wall. He's holding up a shovel and a hourglass um and people have tried and tried and tried to whitewash him out but he keeps seeping back to the surface so it can't get rid of him that's lovely then um kind of staying around that area
這挺悲傷的。從那裡出發，一個非常受歡迎的教堂是波伊斯（Powys）的聖伊許/帕特里西奧教堂（St. Issuu, Patricio），西牆上有一具生鏽彩繪的骷髏。他手裡拿著一把鏟子和一個沙漏，人們試了一次又一次又一次地把他身上的白灰刷掉，但他總是會重新滲透到表面上，所以根本甩不掉他。這真可愛。然後，呃，留在那個地區附近，
there's st michael's and cascob and there's an inscription on the wall which i think is really which i think is brilliant where i kind of that kind of superstition and faith kind of you know kind of the mixture is really good so it's a um about 1700 and the inscription reads oh lord jesus we beseech thee for thy mercy that this holy charm abracadabra make your thy servant does it really say abracadabra? It says abracadabra, yep. Make your thy servant Elizabeth Lloyd from all evil sprites and from all their diseases. Amen. So that's good. So, yep.
有一座卡斯科布的聖米迦勒教堂（St Michael's and Cascob），牆上有一段銘文，我覺得——我覺得這簡直絕了，那種迷信與信仰的結合——那種混合真的很好。所以這大約是 1700 年的，銘文寫道：「哦，主耶穌，我們祈求你的慈悲，願這個神聖的咒語『阿布拉卡達布拉』（abracadabra）使你的僕人伊麗莎白·勞埃德（Elizabeth Lloyd）免受一切邪靈及其疾病的侵害。阿們。」所以這很好。所以，yeah。
And then just very quickly to say that one such evil sprite could be Lilius Addy who's in Scotland. So she was a witch who died in prison in Scotland in 1704 she's buried on the shore of Torrey Bay in Fife and she's they put like a massive sandstone slab over her grave so that she couldn't get out basically and she was a witch because she confessed probably under great torture to having sex with the devil so that was unfortunate.
然後非常快地說，其中一個這樣的邪靈可能是蘇格蘭的莉莉亞斯·阿迪（Lilias Adie）。她是一個女巫，於 1704 年死在蘇格蘭的監獄中，她被埋葬在法夫郡（Fife）托里灣（Torry Bay）的海岸上，他們在她的墳墓上放了一塊巨大的砂岩板，這樣她基本上就無法逃出來了。她之所以被視為女巫，是因為她在極度酷刑下承認了自己與魔鬼發生過性關係，所以這真是不幸。
But basically, her body was dug up in the 19th century. Her skeleton was sold off, made into walking sticks, all of those sorts of stuff. What? I'd happily have such a walking stick. It's awful. It's a terrible thing. I know. And people, there's a group in Scotland that are trying to kind of get her. Bring all the walking sticks back together.
但基本上，她的屍體在 19 世紀被挖了出來。她的骨架被賣掉，被做成了手杖，所有這些亂七八糟的東西。什麼？我倒很樂意擁有一根這樣的手杖。這太可怕了。這是一件可怕的事。我知道。而且人們——蘇格蘭有一個團體正試圖把她——把所有的手杖重新聚在一起。
Yeah, exactly. And bury her properly. Anyway, anyway but just get on them well i kind of so that lady you know admitted to having sex with the devil that's fine but in shropshire there's halston hall where there's a guy called mad jack mighton i don't know if anybody knows of him no okay yeah i know him okay great so you, this fella drank six bottles of port a day. He fed his dog steak and champagne. He went duck shooting naked on a frozen lake. He dressed up as a highwayman and ambushed his guests. He rode a bear into dinner as a kind of a spectacle.
yeah，沒錯，然後好好安葬她。不管怎樣，不管怎樣，但是說回到——那麼那位女士（承認與魔鬼發生性關係，那沒問題），但在什羅普郡（Shropshire）的霍尔斯顿庄园（Halston Hall），有一個叫瘋狂傑克·米通（Mad Jack Mytton）的傢伙，我不知道有沒有人知道他？不，沒有。哦， yeah，我知道他。哦，太好了。所以，這傢伙一天喝六瓶波特酒。他餵他的狗吃牛排和香檳。他光著身子在冰凍的湖面上打野鴨。他把自己打扮成強盜去伏擊他的客人的晚餐，他甚至把一隻熊騎進餐廳作為一種奇觀。
But he was absolutely fine, so there was nothing kind of untoward about his behaviour, and he's buried in the crypt. So, you know, they didn't have to bury him under a big mass of sand, so on and so on. But anyway, the church... It's everyday sexism, isn't it? It is, yeah. But hold on, she'd been having sex with the devil.
但他完全沒事，所以他的行為沒有什麼不正常的地方，他被安葬在地下室裡。所以，你知道的，他們不必把他埋在厚厚的沙堆下，諸如此類。但不管怎樣，那座教堂……這就是日常性別歧視，對吧？確實是， yeah。等等，她可是跟魔鬼發生過性關係耶。
She hadn't been riding a bear. They're two very different things. No, but she didn't actually have sex with the devil, Dominic. She was probably tortured. She died in prison probably because they tortured her I just think we should take a bit of a open minded approach to these okay fine
她又沒有騎著熊。這是兩碼事。不，但她實際上並沒有跟魔鬼發生性關係，多米尼克。她可能是被刑訊逼供的。她死在監獄裡很可能是因為他們對她進行了刑訊逼供。我只是覺得我們應該對這些事情採取一種開放的心態，好吧。
anyway number 8 is Ayn Hallow on Scotland hold on that wasn't even number 8 no no no but these were just kind of this is the preamble I like a preamble okay very very quickly Ayn Hallow is an island um in orkney um and it was once in the grip of a magic spell and it was completely inaccessible to humans
不管怎樣，第八個是蘇格蘭的艾恩霍洛（Ain Hallow）。等一下，那甚至不是第八個？不，不，不，但這些都只是——這是開場白。我喜歡開場白。好吧，非常非常快地，艾恩霍洛是奧克尼群島上的一個島嶼，它曾一度被魔法詛咒所籠罩，完全不為人類所接近。
so and the stories go that it was occupied by the finn folk who are kind of you know sorcerers sort of dementory type people um uh and uh they used to abduct children and all that sort of stuff but basically humans eventually did make it over there and by the salt and the sign of the cross they retrieved the island from the finn folk and they built a little church there and for a long time it was thought that the soil of this Ain Hallow was so sacred and that it would repel anything that was undesirable so even rats and mice so people used to like to go and get a handful of soil to kind of keep all the undesirables from their house anyway really quickly because i don't have very much time um this is uh this is a really kind of ancient old norse church on Orkney. It's just a ruin now. It was kind of rediscovered.
所以，傳說它被芬人（finn folk）佔據，他們是一種——你知道的，巫師之類、有如攝魂怪般的人群，嗯，呃，他們過去常常綁架兒童之類的事情。但基本上，人類最終還是抵達了那裡，藉由鹽和十字架的標誌，他們將島嶼從芬人手中奪了回來，並在那裡建了一座小教堂。在很長的一段時間裡，人們認為艾恩霍洛的土地是如此神聖，以至於它能擊退任何不受歡迎的東西，甚至是老鼠和小鼠，所以人們過去常常去那裡抓一把泥土，以此讓所有不受歡迎的東西遠離他們的房屋。不管怎樣，非常快地，因為我沒有太多時間——這是呃——這是奧克尼群島上一座非常古老的北歐教堂。現在只是一片廢墟。它曾被
It was the church was repurposed into a dwelling in and around the 16th century. Nobody knew it was there until it was discovered by chance in 1851. But it is hugely important, massively under-researched and yeah you can see bits of the Norse kirk, you know the porch, the gables, the naves, the chancel walls. They're kind of all sorts of there. And is it under research because it's so difficult to make you can live there? Is it under research because nobody... You can go out there one day a year.
在大約 16 世紀及前後被重新改造成住宅。沒有人知道它在那裡，直到 1851 年機緣巧合之下被發現。但它極其重要，嚴重缺乏研究，yeah，你可以看到北歐柯克（Norse kirk）的碎片，你知道的，門廊、山牆、中殿、聖壇牆。各種東西都在那裡。是因為它太難到達所以沒人去研究嗎？是因為它太難研究了嗎？你一年只能去那裡一天。
One day a year? Yeah. So no wonder it's difficult to research. Exactly. Anyway, very quickly, because we have no time. Moving on. So what I love about churches is all the stuff in them. Is number nine now this is number nine yeah very quick um number nine okay big shout out to big shout out to saint bothwell's hardin in west sussex it's it's this is the
一年只能去那裡一天？ yeah難怪很難研究。沒錯。不管怎樣，非常快地，因為我們沒有時間了。繼續前進。所以，我對教堂最愛的就是裡頭所有的東西。現在是第九個了，這就是第九個。 yeah，非常快。
preamble again this is the preamble okay big shout out to saint bothwell's hardin in west sussex which has some of the oldest wall paintings in the UK. It's got the Annunciation, the Massacre, Adam and Eve, George and the Infidels, Doom, Flight into Egypt, all there. Amazing. Date to about the 1100s, on the side of a road, cars flying past, nobody knows it's there. Great. And it survived because it was whitewashed? Or was it just so obscure? Correct. Yeah. Okay.
第九個。哦，強烈推薦——強烈推薦西蘇塞克斯郡哈廷的聖博特爾夫教堂（St. Botolph's, Hardham），它擁有英國最古老的壁畫之一。這裡有聖母領報、屠殺、亞當和夏娃、聖喬治與異教徒、末日審判、逃往埃及，全都在那裡。太驚人了。年代大約在 1100 年代，就在路邊，汽車呼嘯而過，卻沒有人知道它在那裡。太棒了。它之所以能存留下來是因為被刷了白灰？還是因為它太默默無聞了？沒錯。 yeah。好吧。
St. Lawrence, Brought it in Buckinghamshire. Brilliant church. On the outskirts of Milton Keynes. It's really great wall paintings. Nothing on the outside. Inside, 15th century wall paint. Massive George and the Dragon. You've got dooms.
白金漢郡布洛頓的聖勞倫斯教堂（St. Lawrence, Broughton）。非常棒的教堂。位於米爾頓凱恩斯（Milton Keynes）的郊外。它有非常棒的壁畫。外表看不出什麼。內部是 15 世紀的壁畫。巨大的聖喬治與龍。還有末日審判。
You've got blacksmiths. You've got all this sort of stuff. What I love is it's got a little panel called the Warning to the Blasphemers. And you've got all these kind what I love is it's got a little panel called the warning to the blasphemers and you've got all these kind of you know contemporary um dressed 15th century fellas and looking all nice and dandy and in the middle is a pieta and Christ is kind of lying there and his body is kind of being pulled apart so it's like the skin is shredded off his arms and legs and there's blood dripping around and these guys um are like you know they're
有鐵匠。有所有這類東西。我最喜歡的是它有一個小面板，叫做「對褻瀆者的警告」，這裡有所有這些——我最喜歡的是它有一個小面板叫「對褻瀆者的警告」，你看到所有這些——你知道的——當代著裝的 15 世紀的傢伙們，看起來都那麼帥氣瀟灑，而在正中間是一個聖母憐子像（pieta），基督就躺在那裡，他的身體彷彿正在被撕裂，就像他的皮膚從四肢被剝落，鮮血四處滴落，而這些傢伙們——就像是——你知道的，他們在
drinking and they're playing you know i don't know backgammon or something and they're swearing on christ's body and basically and and some of them hold up bits of bones and heart and stuff like that and it's um that every time you swear on christ's body or you blaspheme uh you're prolonging christ's suffering there we go anyway the real star number nine is st caddox clank harfin in vale of glamorgan so these one soon not st thomas's not st thomas's in salisbury no it's not this is a better one tom sorry much better actually because the salisbury one is lovely but actually it's been really over restored sorry about that please don't't kill me or hate me.
喝酒，在玩——你知道的，雙陸棋之類的遊戲，他們在基督的身體上發誓。基本上，而且——他們中的一些人還舉著骨頭和心臟之類的碎片，這簡直是——每當你在基督的身體上發誓或褻瀆神明時，你就是在延長基督的痛苦。就是這樣。不管怎樣，真正的明星第九個是格拉摩根谷（Vale of Glamorgan）克蘭哈芬（Clank Harfin）的聖卡多克斯教堂（St Caddox）。所以這些很快——不是索爾茲伯裡的聖托馬斯教堂（St Thomas's in Salisbury）。不，不是這個。這是一個更好的，湯姆，抱歉。實際上好得多，因為索爾茲伯裡的那個雖然很可愛，但實際上被过度修复了。抱歉啦，請不要殺我或恨我。
Anyway, this is a great church. A little whitewashed church in the Vale of Glamorgan. The wall paintings were only discovered in 2008. And they are some of the best in the whole of Europe. Unbelievably beautiful. So you've got a huge George and the Dragon. You've got the Virgin Mary blessing him. You've got the princess.
总之，这是一座很棒的教堂。位于格拉摩根谷的一座小巧的被刷成白色的教堂。这里的壁画直到2008年才被发现。它们是整个欧洲最好的壁画之一。美得令人难以置信。里面有一个巨大的圣乔治与恶龙的形象。还有圣母玛利亚为他祝福的画面。你还能看到公主。
You've got the people in the tower. But what's really cool is it's got the seven deadly sins and the seven acts of mercy. I've seen it. Have you? I've seen it. Oh good, oh good, hooray. I have. It is better than St Thomas' and Salisbury. Yes, okay. No, you're right. Brilliant, thank you. I mean of course you're right but no you're... Oh I'm really glad, phew, okay because I only have about one minute to do the last one but just very no rachel you don't just take your time okay because this is quality this is quality so it's fine all right okay well just really quickly okay so this church is brilliant i've said about the saint george and the dragon it's also got um a death and the gallant which is completely unique so you've got kind of you know a nice again kind
塔楼里还有人。但真正酷的是它有七宗罪和七大善行。我见过。你见过吗？我见过。哦太好了，哦太好了，太棒了。我见过。它比索尔兹伯里的圣托马斯教堂还要好。是的，好吧。不，你是对的。太棒了，谢谢你。我的意思是当然你是对的，不过不，你是……哦，我真的很高兴，呼，好吧，因为我只剩大约一分钟时间讲最后一个了，但是非常——不，雷切尔，你不用着急，慢慢来，好吧，因为这是高质量的，这是高质量的内容，所以没关系，好吧，好吧，那就非常快地说一下，好吧，所以这座教堂太棒了，我刚才说过圣乔治和恶龙的事，它还有一个——呃——“死神与豪侠”，这完全是独一无二的，所以你有一种，你知道的，很好的，又是一种，怎么说呢
of a nice contemporary dandy fellow. And then a skeleton and a shroud kind of like looking over him. Seven Deadly Sins, they are in brilliant condition. And what I love about them is there's like a central beast and it's got multi heads. And the heads kind of come up and in the jaws of each of the kind of subheads um of this beast there's a little panel that contains the each um each of the seven deadly sins and it's just they are so I mean they're just amazing so in each one one of my favorite ones is gluttony which is um there's a man and he's kind of got a big swollen stomach and his uh buttons are popping off his vest and there's a and there's kind of got a big swollen stomach and his buttons are popping off his vest and there are kind of empty glasses all around him.
一种很现代的花花公子形象。然后是一个骷髅和裹尸布俯视着他。七宗罪，它们的保存状况极佳。我最喜欢它们的一点是，那里有一个中心怪兽，它有多个头。这些头向上伸展，在这个怪兽各个子头的血盆大口里，各有一个小方格，里面包含了——呃——七宗罪的每一个罪行，它们真的是——我的意思是它们太棒了，所以在每一个里面，我最喜欢的其中一个就是暴食，那是——呃——有一个男人，他的肚子肿得很大，他背心的扣子都快崩开了，然后有一个——然后他的肚子肿得很大，背心的扣子都快崩开了，周围到处都是空杯子。
And there's a little demon who's pulling back his head and forcing more beer down his neck, kind of forcing him to drink more. And they're just, I mean, they're just so brilliant. And just to say they were discovered completely by chance and they were getting some work done to the wall plate they were repaired doing a little bit of timber repair and the builder saw a bit of red paint and said oh that might be interesting completely by chance and really some of the some of the best in in europe so there we go dominic you should go there okay last one now i'm really worried that we're going to end on a low point because I've kind of just raced through and I've kind of just kept something really
还有一个小恶魔在往后拉他的头，把更多的啤酒灌进他喉咙里，有点像在强迫他喝更多。它们真的是——我的意思是，它们太棒了。顺便说一句，它们完全是偶然被发现的，当时他们正在对墙板进行一些工作，他们在进行一些木结构修复，建筑工人看到了红色油漆的一角，然后说“哦，这可能很有趣”，纯属偶然，而且确实是——欧洲最好的之一——所以，就这样，多米尼克，你应该去那儿看看。好吧，最后一个了，现在我很担心我们会以一个低谷结束，因为我刚才一直在赶时间，而且我刚才一直留着一个非常
quick for last. But anyway, this is Literary Connections. So, you know, loads of literary connections. Thomas Hardy, you know, love of my life. All of that sort of stuff. This one is Saint Michael and All Angels in
快速的放在最后。不过总之，这是文学渊源。所以，你知道的，有很多文学渊源。托马斯·哈代，你知道的，我一生的挚爱。诸如此类的东西。这一座是位于
Hathersage, which is... Do you know it, Tom? Making a noise? No? I think so. Okay, so this isn't a hardy church, but it's basically a 14th century church. Lots of all interesting things,
哈瑟奇的圣迈克尔及诸天使教堂，它……你知道吗，汤姆？在发出声音吗？不？我想是的。好吧，所以这不是一座哈代教堂，但它基本上是一座14世纪的教堂。有很多各种有趣的东西，
but the big thing here is the heirs. They're absolutely everywhere in the church. They were the lords of the manor for about 800 years, so you can see them on the font, the porch, the memorials on the walls. Sorry, that's their surname. Ayres, yeah, sorry. Sorry, E-Y-R-E-S. Basically, in 1854, Charlotte Bronte came here. She attended services with her friend
但这里最重大的事情是艾尔家族。他们在教堂里无处不在。他们大约做了800年的庄园领主，所以你可以在洗礼盘、门廊、墙上的纪念碑上看到他们。抱歉，那是他们的姓氏。艾尔，是的，抱歉。抱歉，E-Y-R-E-S。基本上，在1854年，夏洛特·勃朗特来到了这里。她和她的朋友一起参加了礼拜
who was Ellen Nusey, who was the sister of the newly appointed vicar. And she, basically, Charlotte Bronte took loads from this church and her kind of time in Hathersage to write Jane Eyre, which is great. So the village of Hathersay becomes the village Morton. Henry Nusey, who was the vicar, becomes St. John Rivers, who, you know, says Jane or whatever. And Jane Eyre is obviously named after the Eyres which is great. And then very finally in the churchyard
也就是埃伦·努西，她是新上任的牧师的妹妹。她——基本上，夏洛特·勃朗特从这座教堂以及她在哈瑟奇的时光中汲取了大量灵感来写《简·爱》，这太棒了。所以哈瑟奇村成了莫顿村。作为牧师的亨利·努西成了圣约翰·里弗斯，也就是你知道的，对简说话的那个人等等。而且《简·爱》显然是根据艾尔家族命名的，这太棒了。然后最后在教堂墓地里
apparently that is also apparently the resting place of Robin Hood's great friend Little John Little John? Because in 1784 Captain James Shuttleworth discovered a massive femur,
据说那也是罗宾汉的好友小约翰的长眠之地。小约翰？因为在1784年，詹姆斯·沙特尔沃思船长发现了一根巨大的股骨，
a massive thigh bone that was over a metre long. Oh, it must have been him. Must have been him. So basically, that person, the person the bone was attached to would have been over eight feet tall. And there's only one person in all history. That could be. Why did they think it was Little John?
一根超过一米长的大腿骨。哦，那一定是他。一定是他。所以基本上，那个人，这根骨头所属的那个人身高会超过八英尺。而且历史上只有一个人。可能是他。为什么他们会认为是小约翰？
They probably just wanted tourism or something. Even in 1784. No, I think there's a legend that Little John's hat and coat used to hang his hat and coat in the church and stuff like that.
他们可能只是想要发展旅游业什么的。甚至在1784年。不，我想有一个传说，说小约翰的帽子和外套曾经挂在教堂里之类的。
They kind of knew he was around there. So they just said it. So that was your number 10, Rach? Yeah. And you didn't choose any churches from your native country well I didn't because when you said it to me first of all you didn't include Ireland
他们大概知道他在那附近活动。所以他们就这么说了。所以这就是你的第十名，雷切尔？是的。而且你没有选择任何来自你祖国的教堂？嗯，我没有选，因为当你一开始对我说的时候，你没有把爱尔兰算进去
and actually you gave me the wrong date you gave me the 13th of August so I had been working to different dates so the list was kind of ready for a long time so anyway so i was working to that and then tom i nearly died when you said britain and ireland uh so yeah that was panic well i mean huge apologies to our irish listeners and to you rachel sorry dominic's incompetence i mean i can choose one very quickly but it's uh yeah your fate yes let's have an yes so basically an irish one i will it's
而且事实上你给我的日期错了，你给我的日期是8月13日，所以我一直按照不同的日期在准备，所以这个名单其实准备了很长时间——所以无论如何——所以我一直是按那个准备的，然后汤姆，当你说是英国和爱尔兰时，我差点吓死——所以是的，当时一阵恐慌。好吧——我的意思是，向我们的爱尔兰听众以及你雷切尔致以诚挚的歉意，对不起多米尼克的无能——我的意思是，我可以很快选一个，但它——是的，你的命运，是的，让我们选一个——是的，基本上是一个爱尔兰的，我会的——
you know it's an obvious choice for me but it's my local church we grew up in turnus cross which is a 1920s suburb of cork city in ireland and the church there is amazing uh it was built in uh about 1920 started building in about 1929 i think and but it is the first concrete church in the whole of ireland and but also some people say it's um the first modernist church in ireland but it was designed by a guy called barry burn who was a student of frank lloyd right he was based in chicago he never even got to see the church but it's i mean it's just amazing what i love about it is it kind of takes um it draws on like christ the redeemer so it's a amazing. What I love about it is it kind of takes... It draws on Christ the Redeemer. So it's a massive Christ with open arms.
你知道，对我来说这是一个显而易见的选择，但这是我的本地教堂，我们在爱尔兰科克市郊区的特纳斯克罗斯长大，那是1920年代的郊区，那里的教堂太棒了——它大约建于——大约1929年开始建造，我想，但它是整个爱尔兰第一座混凝土教堂，而且也有人说它是——爱尔兰第一座现代主义教堂，它是被一个叫巴里·伯恩的人设计的，他是弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特的学生，他当时在芝加哥，他甚至从未亲眼见过这座教堂，但它——我的意思是它就是太棒了。我喜欢它的一点是它有点借鉴了——它借鉴了里约热内卢的救世主基督。所以这是一个张开双臂的巨大的基督雕像。
And you kind of walk under the doors under his arms. And it's limestone on the outside. Limestone sculpture. Really interesting kind of... The way the trusses are arranged internally. So it's beautifully lit. Kind of a stepped gable. All of this sort of stuff. Lovely black marble and all that sort of stuff anyway let's put that let's put that in
你可以从他手臂下的门走进去。外面是石灰石。石灰石雕塑。非常有趣的一种——内部桁架的排列方式。所以光线非常好。有一种阶梯状的山墙。诸如此类的事情。可爱的黑色大理石和所有这些东西，总之让我们把那个——让我们把那个
as 11th and you know i think we really need to find a way to put this list somewhere don't we i mean i guess we should put images on online tom shouldn't we we'll put the and yes and when we publicize this on twitter we'll we'll add so Rach if you send us the list that would be great because that's a fantastic array you've given us. I can't thank you enough. And Rach, well Rach this is, you should plug your charity. So you're the director of Britain's leading churches charity. Other church charities are available but they're not as good let's be honest. Yours is the friends of friendless churches so tell us just a tiny bit about this extraordinary named organization okay
列为第11个，你知道的，我觉得我们真的需要找个地方把这个名单放出来，不是吗？我的意思是，我想我们应该把图片发到网上，汤姆，对吧？我们会把——是的，当我们在推特上宣传这个时，我们会加上——所以雷切尔，如果你把名单发给我们，那就太好了，因为你给我们的阵容太棒了。我怎么感谢你都不够。还有雷切尔，好吧，雷切尔，你这个，你应该宣传一下你的慈善机构。所以你是英国领先的教堂慈善机构的主管。还有其他教堂慈善机构，但老实说，它们没有这个好。你的是“无亲友教堂之友”（Friends of Friendless Churches），所以给我们简单介绍一下这个名字不同寻常的组织，好吧
fine uh so the friends of friendless churches we were founded in 1957 and it was basically it was the 13th of july churches were being demolished being declared you know being declared redundant and just being left fall apart and And this Welshman, who was our main founder, Ivor Bulmer Thomas, gathered a group of all his friends. Tom, you spoke about T.S. Eliot. T.S. Eliot was one of the founders. John Betjeman, John Piper, Lady Mander from Wittick, Roy Jenkins, all of these people got together and they called themselves the Friends of Friendless Churches. And they would be the group that goes out and defends these buildings when they are no longer used for worship. And that's basically what we do.
好的——所以“无亲友教堂之友”，我们成立于1957年，基本上是因为在7月13日，当时许多教堂正在被拆除，被宣布为——你知道的，被宣布为冗余并任由其荒废。而这位威尔士人，也就是我们的创始人之一，艾沃·布尔默·托马斯，召集了一群他的朋友。汤姆，你刚才提到了T.S.艾略特。T.S.艾略特就是创始人之一。约翰·贝杰曼、约翰·派珀、来自威蒂克的曼德夫人、罗伊·詹金斯，所有这些人聚在一起，他们称自己为“无亲友教堂之友”。当这些建筑不再用于礼拜时，他们就会成为走出去捍卫这些建筑的群体。这基本上就是我们所做的。
Churches are closing. More churches are probably going to close. But they are some of the greatest buildings. They are the spiritual investment of generations they're like i mean they are regardless i i think they kind of transcend time and race and religion and that they are just saturated with kind of human experience they also contain some of the best art and architecture they're everywhere um and that they should be protected for everybody and not sold off to private individuals and that's what we do. We work in England and Wales. We're non-denominational.
教堂正在关闭。更多的教堂可能也会关闭。但它们是最伟大的建筑之一。它们是几代人的精神投资，我的意思是，无论如何——我认为它们超越了时间、种族和宗教，它们浸透了人类的经验，它们还包含着最好的艺术和建筑，它们无处不在——而且它们应该为所有人得到保护，而不是被变卖给私人个体，这就是我们所做的。我们在英格兰和威尔士工作。我们是非宗派的。
We currently have 60 churches in our care and we take on more every single year. And we do it with a grant of £120,000. So we kind of work on a shoestring. So, yeah. Okay. Well, I can't thank you enough for that. And I think that your selection
我们目前照顾着60座教堂，并且每年都在接管更多。我们依靠12万英镑的拨款来做到这一点。所以我们算是靠微薄的资金在运作。所以，好吧。好吧，我非常感谢你做的一切。而且我认为你的选择
eminently proves what you said about churches. I mean, they're kind of incredible fascination. Well, I guess... Thanks so much. Sorry. I guess what I wanted... Sorry, Tom. She's still going.
完美地证明了你对教堂的看法。我的意思是，它们具有一种令人难以置信的魅力。好吧，我想……非常感谢。抱歉。我想我想要……抱歉，汤姆。她还在说。
Well, no, I guess the reason why I kind of chose these ones is that you don't need to go to kind of... Even the smallest and most obscure church, the one on the side of a motorway, is still packed with history, even if it's, you know, Saxon, inventor saxon inventor of the torpedo von traps it's all there um yeah you know yeah yeah okay thank you very much rach thank you everybody for listening visit your local church
好吧，不，我想我之所以选择这些的原因是，你不需要去那种——即使是最小、最偏僻的教堂，高速公路旁的那个，也依然充满了历史，即使它是，你知道的，撒克逊人，鱼雷的撒克逊发明家冯·特拉普，所有这些都在那儿——是的，你知道的——好的，非常感谢你，雷切尔，谢谢大家收听，去参观你当地的教堂
donate to the friends of friendless churches and most of all listen to the next rest is history we'll see you all next time. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. Thanks for listening to the Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
向无亲友教堂之友捐款，最重要的是，收听下一期的《历史大不同》，我们下次节目再见。再见。再见。感谢收听《历史大不同》。如需收听加长版节目、提前收听、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。